merry Christmas everybody this is uh our
last show for the week nobody's working
there's nobody sitting next to me Ian's
gone of all people Ian's the guy who
wakes up at
7 P.M for an 8pm show and then he shows
up in his pajamas and even this guy is
out for family well I guess actually
that makes sense yeah we miss him though
Luke left today because Luke's got a
Polish mom and uh I'll tell you what
it's it's well that's what he said
because he's like polish mothers are
very much like you got to be back early
you know what I mean yeah but uh but
Jack Murphy's hanging out hey I'm here
good to be here my friend Matt's going
to be here a little bit later it's going
to be a lot of fun good to see you
everybody there's a lot of people who
have no idea what that means I know it
does I'm Jack Murphy follow me on
Twitter at Jack Murphy live on YouTube
Jack Murphy live yeah we there's news
um they're rolling out all these vaccine
mandates right before Christmas when no
one's paying attention and that's one of
the most nefarious things Boston
announced that DC announces that Chicago
announces it and they're doing it just
after the new year and I think a lot of
people are going to comply so we'll
we'll talk about all that stuff we'll
talk about uh you know Joe Biden we got
I want to talk about the story with Elon
Musk he's saying that he's gonna uh he
or he he is paying more taxes than
anyone in history which is effectively
defanging a lot of these leftist
arguments against them and then we've
got some uh I don't know
I gotta bounce you guys nobody's working
right now yep so we've got stories on
timcast.com which we're going to talk
about and then for the most part man
everybody is zoned out people are like I
don't want to talk about this stuff I
don't want to listen I want to go watch
The Matrix well I'll tell you what I did
today I watched The Matrix and we have a
review because I think the Matrix
Resurrection is conservative propaganda
and uh I only mean I'm only half joking
when I say that I actually think they
have a very powerful kind of traditional
message in it which is interesting and
there's also like the movie almost mocks
the left but I think they're serious
with it it's kind of like how girl
Busters was you know they're like this
is what we really believe and you're
like wow really and then they have this
like I don't want to spoil too much I'm
not going to spoil too much but we'll
talk about it later on the show and then
uh you know whatever we'll talk about
Joe Biden or something he wants to
rematch Trump what's going on man
welcome back thanks man good to be here
uh on my way up I'm I'm like reading
about DC vax mandates so I'm uh sort of
just accepting the fact that I'm never
gonna be able to go out to eat or to the
movies or to concert or have a drink or
anything ever again in DC and then I
here at Montgomery County the county
just adjacent to DC is doing something
yep in Maryland yeah man because they
couldn't do it Statewide because where
we are in Western Maryland has already
tried to has already offered up
secession yeah yeah so these westernmost
Counties have said like West Virginia we
would gladly become West Virginia please
right help us Washington County and a
few others are I think I think it's
happened more than once they write
letters and like please take us West
Virginia there's a dude over here who's
got a big sign that says swamp 40 miles
that way and like wear your boots and
there's like a big Trump sign and stuff
like that so look at all that stuff we
also got Lydia hanging out it's just the
three of us I am also here in the corner
pushing buttons I did not take off
tonight I'm happy to be here with you
guys and Jack and Tim it's going to be I
think it's going to be perfectly animate
even though we have fewer people here so
I'm stoked well this is like the very
first time I was ever on the show oh
yeah there's only a few of us right
right the first time you came on just us
hanging out no Luke no uh that was like
uh February 2020. yeah yeah man just
before the world ended and that's right
well what we got to talk about before we
get started we've got an awesome sponsor
this is bio trusts keto Elevate C8 MCT
oil powder we shot these guys out all
the time I love the stuff I've been
doing keto now uh I would say like how
long it's been four or five months you
know it's been a while it's been it's
been really great for me it's a decent
amount of weight and I love putting this
stuff in my coffee it it kind of it kind
of makes it creamy it's like coffee
creamer almost it is medium chain
triglycerides which is perfect for P for
you when you need energy and I'll and
I'll admit you know initially when I
wasn't getting sugar in the morning when
I cut that stuff out I was feeling it I
was feeling sluggish I started adding
this stuff to my coffee I started adding
more fats and avocados you know later on
for lunch and stuff and I started
feeling better and better and better but
it happened almost instantly so if you
go to eat right and feelwell.com you can
secure your supply of Keto Elevate for
51 off today you get a 60 day money back
guarantee this is great stuff it's good
for energy levels healthy appetite
Management Mental clarity and focus and
I gotta tell you I can attest to that
athletic performance not even kidding
I've been skating more and since
starting keto uh several months ago I I
just feel like a million bucks I'm not
even I'm not exaggerating I've just been
feeling better I've been skating better
and the weird thing was and this should
be very obvious when there was like I
think it was we did a little party and
there was some you know sugar and people
are like you can have a cheat day it's
no big deal the next day it was like
being smacked in the face with a 2x4 and
I'm like dude I'm not doing that again
I'm eating right and it's feeling good
so again go to eat rightandfeelwell.com
and you'll get free shipping on every
order for every order today BioTrust
donates a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
bio trust hit their goal of six million
meals this year you get free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their new e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods for uh with every order
you make so again eat right and feel
well com but don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member your
membership is what sustains us the
journalists we have I did a check today
we have 31 employees I'm very I'm
surprised by that we had a holiday party
and I'm like who are all these people in
my house isn't it crazy like and I know
who they are uh who they are and what
they do and I'm like man we got a lot of
people working here but I'll tell you
this
most of the people who are working here
they're doing editorial stuff they're
doing journalism they're doing fact
checking and then we have a couple other
shows and it really is about expanding
and doing more work and making sure that
what you know at you as members are
helping us to make sure we build a
powerful foundation and I mean look I'll
just say it For Better or For Worse
become the the mainstream press become
the dominant you know uh media
institutions and maybe at some point we
will have to be supplanted by someone
else but for the time being the
establishment is broken and that's what
we see the challenge and with your help
we will do it so smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and I I know
there's already people uh putting in a
bunch of super chats and they're saying
that you know we've got to read them
because there was a an issue with Jack
last week on Elijah and Sydney Watson's
show and look I'll say I'll say first
and foremost
we're not a drama Channel we don't do
drama you know I understand that
something happened and everybody's super
chatting and expecting me to read
something but I will say
we will address it we will read your
super chats by all means super chat but
we don't do
um silliness like if you have legitimate
questions and legitimate conversation to
be had that will move things forward
definitely will be into it if you're
posting memes and jokes and like having
a laugh or whatever we'll read one or
two maybe but I'm not gonna read for a
half an hour because you guys want to
make you know jokes or whatever like I
mean I'm not trying to be a dick or
anything the goal of this show has
always been can we like maximize the
conversation and get the best ideas
across as possible and I think that's
why we we get so many super chats
because people are usually offering up
really good questions and helping us
have that conversation so I just try to
keep I try to I try to stay out of the
weeds there are a lot of YouTubers they
talk about me all day they're like oh
dimple did this dimple did that you know
The Young Turks did it recently and I'm
like I don't I don't I'd rather not do
that I'd rather talk about the things
that are impacting Our Lives the things
that are are causing us Strife the
things we need to overcome what we can
do to improve ourselves and I typically
things that just I feel like are
important worth talking about so we'll
we'll address it simply because I think
it you know should be because you know
people are asking for it but I will say
for the most part don't expect we're
going to have some ridiculous I don't
know joke Fest where we just make fun of
people or anything like that but uh at
any rate if you want to get your super
chats in by all means you're free to do
so and uh let's just read the news man
let's do it we got the story from
timcast.com Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot
warns unvaccinated residence your time
is up and she said it just like that too
she said we didn't want to get to this
point actually I should read it like
Lori Lightfoot because she's Beetlejuice
touch talks like this we didn't want it
to get to this point but uh given the
situation we find ourselves in we have
no choice beginning January 3rd you must
show proof you are fully vaxed 200 bars
I haven't seen that move in a really
long time by the way good impression I
don't know if I'm doing a good one
uh she says to enter bars restaurants
fitness centers and entertainment and
recreational venues where food and drink
are served but the best part was when
she said where is it do we even have it
on here here we go to put it simply if
you have been living vaccine free your
time is up if you wish to live life as
with the ease to do the things you love
you must be vaxxed this health order May
pose an inconvenience to the
unvaccinated and in fact it is
inconvenient by Design I had to read it
like a villain yeah because that was one
of the most villainous like statements
on vaccine mandates from any executive I
don't know that one from Biden was
pretty bad they're like if you don't get
vaccinated you face a long dark cold
winter and you're going to overwhelm the
hospitals and basically you're going to
die I I don't I don't yes it was bad but
I don't agree right when I when I saw so
that was from ziense or whatever the
coronavirus task force guy on Biden's
Administration he said the unvaxed can
be expecting a winter of death and you
know like suffering or whatever because
you'll overwhelm the hospitals but
that's more like what you know I imagine
that as if I was watching a movie
there's like a hooded figure issuing
like a prophetic warning and like
shaking a bony finger you will face
death
and that's not the real villain but this
one she's like if you've been living
vaccine free your time is up that's like
Skeletor straight up being like I'll get
to He-Man you know like not like just
like a warning you know they're just
gonna try to make your life as miserable
as possible he said it
the Bellagio was like we're going to
take away your life liberty and pursuit
of happiness unless you inject yourself
with this you know this medication you
want Liberty do what we say yep but you
won't even get Liberty if you do it
that's the crazy thing no not at all and
in fact the DC area much uh sorry
Washington DC just came out with its own
vax mandate today as a matter of fact
and in there it gave a definition of
vaccinated you know and it's like two
shots you're only one shot if you're a
kid two shots if you're adult of course
that's gonna change there's no Liberty
there you're gonna just keep having to
get the shot but I'm faced with now like
I'm literally I I can't go to any
restaurants in DC you gotta move I gotta
move I wish there were that easy I'm
divorced it's been a long time it's been
12 years we've been divorced the kids
are here I'm not you know I have two
choices I can either abandon my kids or
I can kidnap them either way these are
two you know obviously I can't do either
one of those so I'm I'm stuck right and
uh you know I wish people would
understand that when they come at me
about the vaccine it's like also I have
split custody and this is a thing
divorced families are facing all across
the country where the parents don't
agree on what to do about the vaccine
well now you now there's no question
your kids have to be faxed period I mean
they're making it that way it used to be
you know so we had that conversation
about you know your kids want to do
Sports and then we got net debate now it
doesn't even matter that's not even a
question anymore now it's I there
there's not going to be any legal
defense there there will be
but I'll say this first and foremost
it's one thing to be like if I want my
kids to play sports they got to get the
vaccine because of these rules now
they're just going to be like if you
want your kid to go to a restaurant have
to go to a gym to go to the schools to
do any of that stuff they have to be
vexed so it's either they stay at home
all day or they get the vaccine so I
think that when it comes to a court con
like a court argument where you're
saying you don't you don't want your
kids yeah there's no choice
boom done exactly yeah so I I literally
have no choice and people people don't
like Nuance the trolls don't like any
nuance and they give me a hard time
about our conversation that we had a
couple of months ago and I'm just faced
with the fact that I'm no longer am I
I'm no longer gonna be able to go to
restaurants Museum bars nightclubs
theaters you know music venues whatever
and even in the adjacent counties
Montgomery County Arlington County
they're going to be doing the same thing
Montgomery County just announced it I'm
never going to be able to go to the
Metropolitan Museum of Art ever again in
New York City I'm like being deleted out
of society because I'm a strong healthy
you know man that has maybe I think I've
had it before I remember March 2020
after CPAC man everybody was sick after
yeah well and people got it at Sea back
yeah I'm going to Chicago and we're
leaving uh tomorrow at some point and
this is probably the last time I'll ever
go to Chicago no joke no I feel
fortunate that I've been able to travel
the world already right because so many
people can't but uh and and the the
response from the people in The Cult are
just like why don't you just do as
you're told and I'm like I because I
don't agree with it whether whether
you're vaccinated or not I think the
mandates are absolutely wrong in Austria
they're bringing out inspectors to go
track people down and find them so what
I think is going to happen is what
Chicago is basically saying is for the
foreseeable future until we deem it safe
it's never gonna be safe not ever ever I
uh I do have TSA Pre so I don't have to
take my shoes off when I go on the
airlines but I still watch all those
people go through the line taking off
their shoes taking their laptops out of
their back all these things it's not
that that is never going to change I
suspect the mask on the airplane
probably never going to change oh yeah I
mean who was it someone already came out
and said they should be permanent was it
fouchy I think it was yeah I think fauci
was like everybody should wear masks
forever right and despite the fact that
two CEOs of Airlines came out and talked
about how the air filters inside those
planes make for like the cleanest
possible air you could ever be in
possibly like takes out 99 of any
possible covid uh you know infectious
particles and whatnot yeah these things
are never going to change the new
Society we have to deal with you know
how they have those when you're in the
plane they have the the fan you can
unscrew the thing and it blows the air
out yeah so have you ever sat next to
someone on a plane who farts a lot
it happens right because what happens is
there's Le there's lower it's a lower
pressure in a higher altitude
so the plane is pressurized for science
notice check it out the plane is the
plane is pressurized but it's still
lower pressure than you would be on the
ground and so the gas in your body
expands and makes it more likely for you
to fart well I've traveled so much man
I'll let you in on a tip many people may
already know this if you travel but I
used to fly twice a week so what I would
do is I would open the vent and have the
the fan blow down to my right side to
create a barrier and so when the fart
would come out the air would hit it and
push it away you think I'm kidding it
works it works and so I bring this up
because it should be true for anything
including you know the droplets yeah you
turn the fan on you have it below next
to you and you got a little wind barrier
pushing away the air and it pulls in air
from other directions so not not only
that but you you're right you got the
filters in these in these airplanes they
don't care man one thing I've noticed
I've been traveling so much as well I've
got like executive Platinum Pro status
on American now nobody gives a crap
about wearing masks in the airport I
have not been wearing a mask in any
airport I don't wear one until I get to
the point of going on to the into the
gate right down into the airplane nobody
cares I've seen people walk up with no
mask on they don't say they just hand
them a mask I don't say anything the
only time that they require it is on the
plane you know what not even all the
time then they do require in airports
but there's no enforcement for the most
none like a TSA agent is going to walk
up isn't going to walk up to you
randomly and be like put on a mask sir
no one says anything no one says
anything into that plane though right
and then all of a sudden they're like
federal law says there's no federal law
no it's a trick they're doing there's a
federal law that grants the President
right to issue executive orders and the
President issued an executive order and
now they're claiming a federal law no
right and this is this is emblematic of
the problem of the bureaucratic state
where they create these vague laws and
then they Empower this whole
administrative state to then then
administer the laws and whatever the way
they see fit and then they they issue
these rules these mandates and then the
the courts will adjudicate them and
effectively it becomes law at that point
but you have basically an army of
technocrats deciding the way that we
have to live our lives today and it's
out of the power of the legislature why
hasn't Congress sat down and actually
debated these very things on the floor
of Congress and decided whether or not
the people want to have that those times
have come and gone like that democracy
yeah Republicans you see the Babylon B
article it was like in in it was like it
was like a terrible blow for democracy
majority representatives make decisions
right they're blaming it all on the one
West Virginia senator and it's like well
what about the other like 50 guys that
didn't vote for it as well it's
ridiculous yeah and you know what kudos
to that guy for for holding his ground
and making his decision he's under a lot
of pressure I don't understand why he
still caucuses with the Democrats he
doesn't vote with them considering going
in independent independent he should he
should and the fact that they try to lay
it all on him is just a ridiculous
cop-out it's it's part of their the
olinsky strategy of isolating targets
and like funneling all of the energy
onto them and hopefully making it
personal and hopefully getting them to
crack it's in the book rules for Rules
for Radicals and they do it they isolate
people they target them how I've seen
people do that in my personal life we
got it I found it from Babylon B it says
in stunning blow to democracy
legislation decided by majority of
elected representatives oh my gosh I
love it because they keep saying like
how come one man is stopping us and it's
like it's 51 Senators
you're insane in a stunning blow
basically uh democracy Works in Action a
majority of elected representatives deny
the passage of the bill wow somebody
somebody just super chatted saying that
they were denied seeing their kids
because by a judge because they're not
vaccinated I'm sorry to hear that for
you dude I I I I I I've heard this a
number of times we've seen court orders
where parents were not allowed to see
their own children because of the vax
thing I don't know I don't know if we're
gonna win this one the vaccine yeah I
think the vaccine mandates will become
law and people will get their routine
and Jack actions and they're not you
know give it give it five years and No
One's Gonna even question it and the
reason is I think you've got cult
members and cowards and that makes up
the bulk of what this country is so I
can't remember who well first there was
Clifton Duncan who had an amazing tweet
he said something to the effect of my uh
disdain for kovidiots has been you know
superseded by my my disdain for those
who know something is wrong and refuse
to speak up yeah
so you know every single person who
watched this in in in the beginning and
said I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say
anything I'm not gonna put any risk to
myself and are now suffering the
consequences I mean it's too late the
time to speak up was a while ago now
that Chicago and DC and these other
places are rolling these things out and
we we saw what happened in New York they
will comply regular people will drop to
their knees to fellate the state with
with a smile on their face no maybe not
a smile on their face maybe they'll be
crying while they do it but like let's
be real they're gonna do it and then
what that means is there will be
outliers there will be
um people who refuse to participate a
lot some of these people who oppose many
of them who oppose the mandates are
vaccinated and these people will find
themselves in the woods
you know what are the the metaphorical
Woods right you could still go to the
grocery store you can still walk around
on the streets you think they're really
going to come after grocery stores 100
yes in Austria it's a mandate period
even in your own home you must be
vaccinated so they're hiring inspectors
to do research and track people down and
then issue them a 3 600 Euro fine every
quarter if they do not get vaccinated
well in DC not only now can they issue
you a fine but they can revoke your
business and driver's licenses they
can't do it they do it and people drop
to their knees and say I will do
anything you say because they're losers
they're gonna look take my driver's
license take my business license I will
not comply I'm not complying I'm never
going to comply period end of story it
would be nice if we could like maybe if
it happens to me we can find a lawsuit
and try to fight this but there's
absolutely no way at this point because
look it's the more they tell me I have
to do it the less I'm interested in
replying yes exactly I will not ever
comply not you know what the issue is
I will not bend the knee to slimy
cultists
you can show me all the signs in the
world that I'm going to say when the
evil people are beating it's like this
imagine you've got
um a despotic king and he's evil as evil
can be and they beaten torture in maim
and do all this really awful stuff and
then they say we've we are going to
manage everyone eat these delicious
pomegranates I'd be like you can't make
me do anything I don't care right I like
pomegranates right you know I mean I
think vaccines are great right but the
state taking this power it's only going
to get substantially worse so for me
it's like
it's very obvious
if
this is the path we're on you can only
imagine how insane it will be a year
from now because you think about what
the the past two years have been like
first it was two weeks then it was just
wear a mask we've seen the memes it's
just this it's just this eventually you
see in Australia they're rounding
they're they're rounding people up and
putting them in camps and they're
justifying it and and I'll tell you how
scary it is yeah when Claire Lehman of
Colette is one of the cheerleaders I
know for arresting people without due
process and bringing them to a camp and
saying it's normal yo we are in trouble
Man how what what does her deal dude
because she was posting Instagram
pictures from like I guess the Olympic
team like stayed there briefly and
saying like this is who's staying there
Timmy hot babes yeah that's who was
staying there man don't you want to be
there with the hot babies do you
remember when there was a hot minute
when Colette was like oh right on point
right on The Cutting Edge like really
doing the thing that they're supposed to
do really saying the right things doing
like actual science and thinking about
it and Reporting on real anti-woke stuff
and then now she's like it's just the
Olympic team man don't worry about it
well she was making it seem like it was
all hot babes right when it was actually
just one propaganda moment from a year
ago or whatever right exactly so they
have these um do you think she did that
unwittingly or is she an agent now
I think she's scared that the state will
will take everything away from her yeah
and she's in this position where she's
not that famous but she's famous enough
and she knows it she knows her option is
stand on principle and be persecuted or
get on your knees and fellate the state
and at least you'll you'll be you'll be
you'll be you'll be fed you regularly
look all this does is confirm to me that
what we're doing in the liminal order
even makes more sense we're building an
independent Network separate from the
institutions we're finding ways to do
our business with each other invest in
each other's companies all this drama
that's going on around me right now I
literally could not give one single F
because all we're doing right now is
like building businesses that are going
to change the world we're building ways
that people can get independent access
and direct access to beef for example
look up modern tea man he's working on
getting a way to get direct access from
the consumers to the beef producers so
we can cut out the middlemen we're
trying to find all kinds of solve
education problems Communications
problems because you're gonna have to
get get meaning safety security
entertainment culture and arts all from
independent networks instead of the
institutions because institutions want
you fat sick jailed or you know tied to
your desk in debt for the rest of your
life that's what they I think there's a
lot of people who are choosing they know
it's wrong they know what's going on is
wrong and they're lying to themselves
and just going along with it because you
know people are tribal beings so there's
like this dude I know who uh he's
tweeting about how he's like I got the
third shot and I was like you're getting
the fourth yep
and I'm liking the fifth and the sixth
and they're like it's endemic it's going
to be like a flu shot and I'm like yeah
I know but you never got a flu shot
before dude like I know you right and
all of a sudden you're just accepting
these these this this new normal I never
got a flu shot ever I never get the flu
shots but she's a kid I got one but I do
have the measles mump and rubella yeah I
do have the polio pertussis all those I
got I've got more vaccines than the
average person substantially true I've
talked about before yeah I was traveling
so they give you all these crazy
different shots yeah and I received the
flute it makes sense you're going to
places where you can catch the disease
just by standing it's gonna be amazing
it's going to be I think it might it I
think it's gonna be 36 feet at the at
the peak and it's going to be 25 foot
walls 75 feet by 100 feet and then we're
building the new studio it's going to be
slightly bigger than the room we're in
the room we're in now is about uh 15 by
30 15 by 32 I think actually
and the the one we're building is going
to be 25 by 40. oh dang so we're gonna
have a much bigger room and it's going
to have uh it's gonna have one big glass
window overlooking the the work facility
it's going to be amazing and so what
we're doing there is for one we're going
into a place where we don't got to worry
about any of this stuff and maybe maybe
it's bad that you know we Retreat or
whatever but man
I was in we were in the New Jersey area
we were trying to buy a building and
everything started to fall apart when
covet happened and then ultimately we
decided you know we we could barely go
out because they had to stay at home
orders and so it wasn't back then it was
interesting because no one was forcing
you to stay home it was just like we
were kind of doing it because we're like
okay what else do we do well there was
nowhere to go yeah yeah everything was
closed down yeah and so we would just
sit around but we had a backyard we had
a fire pit Ian would make fires and we'd
hang out big skate park I remember
seeing that I remember seeing that the
first time I was like it wasn't it
wasn't super big it was like it was like
15 feet by 60 feet or something like
that
I guess that's no not 60 feet actually
yeah maybe it no maybe it was 50 feet I
think it was 50 feet so it was like a
big concrete platform so we were able to
exercise we were able to barbecue and
have fires But ultimately I was like
dude this stuff's getting worse you know
uh like we need to get out of here and
so we decided to move out here now it's
expanding Chicago DC uh um Boston they
they are absolutely going to go National
with the mandates it is going to affect
every I don't I don't see the red States
escaping this
but at the very least you know in West
Virginia we are so far removed from
everything that I really don't see
enforcement as being possible right
right and it comes down to the county
sheriff ultimately right is the county
sheriff going to enforce these things
and one thing that I remember when uh
the Virginia governor was making noise
that they were going to try to pass
legislation that was going to really
curtail second amendment rights a bunch
of county sheriffs got together and were
like we will not enforce this come at us
and at the same time the West Virginia
legislature or at least one of the
legislators there was like Hey all you
county is in Virginia if you don't want
to do that come on over here to West
Virginia and people act like it's such a
crazy thing but um hello why does West
Virginia exist in the first place
because the Civil War happened well I
know but they but they had different
political ideas and they split up like
this is not an this is not an insane
idea to have the states disassemble and
reassemble in some capacity yo it it's a
it's a meme but uh I think Civil War is
inevitable I absolutely do because in
Boston and Chicago I know people in
Chicago because I I'm that's Dom from
there and a bunch of people I know have
been posting on things on Facebook like
I'm scared they're gonna force me to do
this yeah it's crazy to hear from people
I know being like what do I do I'm gonna
lose my job what do I do they're gonna
make me do this and it's just like you
have to leave
you have to leave y'all vote for this
that's the funniest thing some of these
people are Biden voters Democrat voters
and with a smile on their face they went
in there and they rubber stamp Democrat
now they're going why is this happening
to me
because uh people voted for Rhonda
Santos I think they're pretty happy with
their choice dude hair margin though man
right remember you barely beat Gillum
barely beat him imagine the difference
in the National conversation too if
Gillen had won and DeSantis wasn't a
voice and then Gillum was found naked
drugged out passed out at a gay at a gay
orgy or something like that and and it's
crazy that you have Navy veterans not
that there's anything wrong with that
well you just think about the kind of
person you you have to choose from in
terms of leadership right an
irresponsible you know partier or a Navy
veteran and people almost went for the
guy who was not a leader look I got no
issue with people wanting to have gay
orgies and do drugs I I'm very
libertarian I'm like this is this is
what makes America great you go off and
you do your thing and as long as you're
not hurting other people just you know
leave kids out of it leave us out of it
and you do your thing and you'll be
happy
but when it comes to leadership I think
we need somebody with leadership
experience yes and the state almost went
for Gillum instead of DeSantis there's a
lot of things about this from just you
know I don't agree with everything
DeSantis does he's been criticized over
Free Speech issues
but I would take the military veteran
over the you know drug abusing partier
guy don't you think though if it comes
down at a federal level that Gillum or
not Gillum um DeSantis he'll resist
Tennessee governor of Del resist West
Virginia they'll resist a federal I mean
look we already have
in practice today across the country
states actively resisting federal law
that's why I'm saying Civil War because
look but but marijuana hasn't caused a
civil war this is different dude
there's a federal law and the states are
saying no it's that that's not the issue
I I could care less I'm sorry I could
not care less as the appropriate that's
the correct way to say it I could not
care less if California legalized every
drug in the planet and then some I don't
live there I don't care it has nothing
to do with me but when cities start
saying You must undergo a permanent and
irreversible medical procedure people
flee those cities and they go to Red
areas and some of these people are you
know normies they're not going to be
voting some of them might vote Democrat
but what you're doing is right now in
this country what did Bill Maher say
there can't be there can't be a Civil
War in this country because the
Mason-Dixon Line would go through Nana's
Kitchen says the audience but that's
because we had nothing but an
ideological polarization what the
vaccine minutes are doing is creating a
geographical polarization now you've got
people like me who lived in the Philly
suburbs who moved to West Virginia
because I'm like I will not comply or
live under the boot of these despots so
I go to the place where everyone's like
we got guns buddy and I'm like I would
like some of those guns too sir let's go
the people who live in these cities who
say no to the mandates have been fleeing
and they're going to Red areas so now
the the ideological polarization where
you've got people in the New York area
who are mixed now New York City is hard
left these are the people who gleefully
all line up together to get on their
knees to fellate the state
and then you have the people who are
like I ain't doing that moving out right
so my my Vector on this was
federal law needs to be enforced
so there will be areas of the country
who resist the enforcement of the
federal law not it's not the federal law
bro it's the state laws it's the local
laws but you think basically you think
that the Tennessee governor is going to
be like all right everybody get vexed
why would he do that that's what I'm
saying I'm not saying that I'm saying
that Mayor Bill de Blasio is going to
say I'm going to take away your paycheck
yeah and then 20 of the city is going to
say we will leave New York City do it
then you're going to have those 20
percent that lean conservative moving
into more conservative areas and the
polarization is now geographical yeah
it's accelerating then you get the June
26 2022 Supreme Court ruling on Roe v
Wade
the left seems to think Roe v Wade is
done for and if that's the case now you
have hard leftist overtly Progressive or
communist or socialist factions in
cities
and red states that have become
overwhelmingly red and then you get a
wedge issue blue States saying we are
going to run uh you know abortion
clinics in violation of you know federal
law or whatever and then you'll end up
with people fighting over it so have you
heard my assessment on that regard my my
potentialities I've stated about this no
so NBC news Slate a bunch of left
journalists said that based on the oral
arguments on Roe v Wade on the
Mississippi Law the Supreme Court will
overturn Roe v Wade June 2022. that's
what the left believes I don't know if
it'll actually happen because who knows
many of these conservatives are going to
be like well it's it's settled law but
let's say they do what does that really
mean well it means 12 states have
trigger laws which will instantly ban
abortion
then you're going to have the midterms
and it's going to get rowdy if a red
wave actually happens Republicans will
absolutely put forth a bill to federally
ban abortion they absolutely will and
they will have the votes to do it now I
don't know if it's definitive I'm just
saying if the Supreme Court does this if
there's a red wave
the Republicans very likely would do
this Joe Biden very likely would veto it
then comes 2024. you now have
geographically polarized regions the
cities have become overwhelmingly blue
and subservient to the state and the red
states have become overwhelmingly
libertarian and anti-establishment
and then you get a Donald Trump Victory
or around a Santa's Victory and they say
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to sign the federal abortion ban
and the moment they do like John podesta
asked of the West Coast you will see
blue states start to act overtly in
defiance of federal law and seek to
secede or maybe that's too much maybe
modern sensibility to prevent them from
doing it I guarantee you though if we
ever get to the point where there's a
federal abortion ban you will see blue
States defy that and then you will
probably see
conservative and Republican executive
Authority going in and shutting these
things down which results in a dramatic
escalation of conflict when you have
geographical polarization plus States
defying federal law to the point where
it's the issue of
babies you know an abortion yeah I think
it's very simple
when it comes to marijuana laws you are
not going to see a conservative be like
we have to stop these dispensaries
when it comes to abortion you absolutely
will have conservatives being like we
have to go in and stop them from killing
babies right you know there is an
interesting moral argument to be had
here about making a union with somebody
who has a different moral framework for
example when the union was being formed
back in Revolutionary times there was a
lot of people plenty up north who didn't
want to be in a country with the slave
states but there was a moral argument to
be had which is if we don't form a
country with the slave states they will
then form their own country and then
their country will be based on this
immoral thing and it'll be left alone to
prosper and so the moral argument was
actually to incorporate those slave
states into the Union so that over time
the idea of natural law and natural
rights would be able to overcome slavery
and that led to a civil war it let but
that was a process that was set in
motion and the Civil War resolved that
issue and then we resolved it right so
there is a question and I don't think so
I I I think it resolved slavery in the
sense that that was it and then it took
a couple years before we finally totally
purged it but the conflict of The Civil
Wars never stopped it's really
interesting how it's probably a bit
reductive to frame it this way but you
know just reading history and following
the presidency and the elections when I
see like everyone's like this is all
because of Obama when Obama got elected
and then I'm like okay so I read about
Obama and everyone's like Obama got
elected because of bush it's all because
of bush then you go back to 2000 Gore
versus Bush then you go back to Clinton
there is always something that as a
catalyst leads us to this moment of
polarization and I think it's fair to
say that in many ways the Civil War
never ended but I'll give you a better
example to understand you know the
Simplicity of this it's not a
complicated thing it's not a conspiracy
theory it's very simple there's this
really great meme it's not really a meme
it's kind of just like a tweet
and they say how um geographical
formations from the Paleolithic Era
affects modern day voting practices and
what they show is that they're in this
in the American South there used to be a
coastline which layered a bunch of
minerals in a band across Southern
States this created the most fertile
Farmland that so then when the the
plantation owners moved there they
brought all their slaves to this fertile
Farmland then when slavery ended and
today that area is overwhelmingly
Democrat and always votes Democrat so
the people are pointing out how this
geographical formation ultimately
resulted in this band of democrat voters
in the South so what I mean to say is I
read about the Civil War
I read about was it 1872 or 1876 where
they where they they decided the
president by committee
I don't recall this one so this is um
let me see if I can pull this one up I
think it was 1872. I could be wrong it
might have been six the 1872 election
let's see
um no maybe it was the next one
one of these elections was uh decided by
committee and it was because there was a
dispute among uh the states as to who
which electors were real and which ones
were like the legitimate ones and this
resulted in a compromise that ended the
um the Reconstruction boy that sounds
awfully familiar to a memo that I heard
was written and presented to Mike Pence
sometime in January it was 76. yeah uh
it was a compromise between Democrats
and Republicans the Democrats of course
were the Southern uh slave owners and
racists and uh you know after the Civil
War was over you ended with the Union
going and occupying the south in the
Reconstruction Era and then this
election happened and it was so
contentious that there was fear the
Civil War was going to break out again
and so they said what do we do to make
sure that doesn't happen we will
compromise and so they ultimately said
okay Democrats I think they gave it to
the Democrats right let's see who who
actually became president
um
I think it was the Democrat I'm not sure
but ultimately they were like this will
end reconstruction or I think they ended
reconstruction in exchange for the
Republican getting it I can't remember
um I was reading it before yeah James
Buchanan all this stuff so uh anyway it
was it says it was the second of five
presidential elections in which the
person who won the most popular vote did
not win the election
the results of the main election
of five a person didn't win the quality
content yeah
okay so there we go electoral disputes
in the compromise of 1877. so I started
reading about this and then I'm like oh
wow they were still fighting then you
read about how the Democrats you know
fought back after losing the civil war
with the Klan then you read about how
this resulted in the Civil Rights like
this ultimately brought us the Civil
Rights era and how the Democrats decided
to change their strategy in other ways
and it history is really dependent upon
which which political tribe you believe
in the Democrats will tell you that it's
it's at this point in the Civil Rights
era that Democrats realize the Folly of
their ways and decided to help those who
are minorities because that was the path
towards winning and the Republicans
adopted the southern strategy and
decided to start working with the
racists and uh I don't believe that's
true I don't either the other the other
issue the other idea which is a bit more
conspiratorial is that Democrat
politicians realized the path towards
suppressing minorities and maintaining
their racism was to control these groups
and thus they felt that that was you
know their path forward I mean Matt
Stoller we've talked about Matt before
uh he wrote an amazing book where where
he outlined I believe the guy's name was
Fred Dutton I could be wrong on that
where he was a democratic strategist in
the 60s and he wanted to capture the
vote of minorities and homosexuals and
Independent Women and feminist women
because he believed that that was the
way to gain power and they wanted to
become anti-white male and that was the
turn that happened in the 60s and the
70s and we still see that play out today
I mean the stats
who was that
um they ran against who was that it was
the landslide it wasn't um it wasn't it
was who ran against Nixon
was the guy who was like I'm gonna form
a coalition of of the minorities and the
women and the downtrodden then he got
like obliterated you did in the election
here's what people need to understand
about these elections so this wasn't uh
1980 this was 1984 right I think so so
here's what people really don't get
about what a 49 State uh Landslide is
1984 election come on was it Minnesota I
think look at all these Wikipedia's got
everybody
uh was it where is the United States
come on Wikipedia there we go United
States you're not a presidential
election there we go Minnesota yep it
was Walter Mondale and Reagan and you
know what people don't realize first
when I say 49 State Landslide you what
do people imagine they imagine out of
100 million people 90 million people
voted one One Direction and everyone's
cheering and celebrating and saying this
is the guy we wanted and we all in
agreement in this country is Unified
yeah no that wasn't it wasn't like that
at all and so younger people don't get
this Ronald Reagan got 54 million votes
to Walter mondale's 37 million it was 58
to 40 percent
so it's absolutely decisive in the era
where we're used to things being 48 to
48 and decided by 77 000 votes and
whatnot this is
nearly half the almost half the country
opposing Ronald Reagan but 49 states
granting their electoral votes the
Electoral College that's right well I
mean this is why because these 49
landslides tend to favor Republicans
this is one of the this
you're making a face like it's not true
no I I think statistically speaking you
could favor either party but
historically speaking right it's been
Nixon it's been Reagan right interesting
was it Nixon was was weren't there three
oriented landslides we are a union of
States I believe in that the question
this comes up every election right it's
like but the question we need to ask
ourselves is like how would you induce
States into a union today
you have to give them power yeah this is
about keeping the union together and
this is what people don't understand
about being hardcore ideological even on
a moral level versus statesmanship and
Prudence how are you going to actually
get something done and is it okay to
make compromises on certain values here
and there in order to have your primary
values or the one that's most important
to you have success statesmanship is an
entirely different thing than being an
ideologue and statesmanship requires
prudence and Prudence is difficult
Prudence by its very definition is about
making tough decisions between two
competing interests that you have and
that's what people are facing all across
the country right now when it comes to
do I comply with this Max mandate do I
have my kid take the vax if he doesn't
take the vaccine he can't go to school
if he doesn't get educated then he can't
get a job he doesn't get a job etc etc
or do I stand up for this I mean this is
why Prudence is such a difficult thing
to teach it's a difficult thing to
experience statesmanship is way
different than just writing a book about
Theory and trying to say this is the way
everything should be Ibraham Kennedy for
example is not a Statesman right right
he's an ideologue he's not a guy that
knows how to get things done and make
comments I've never heard about it they
admit it yeah there's like I guess
there's some interview where he says we
realize that everything was
indoctrination so we decided why don't
we indoctrinate yeah like why I get it I
respect it that's the funny thing too
like everything like is indoctrination
yes and it's it's funny how there's a
lot of people calling for Banning books
in schools
I just find that really funny the
critical race Theory stuff and I'm like
yeah I don't know if we really want to
ban the books from the schools we want
to ban the Praxis of the books right
like the teachers should explain the
books to kids you know the stuff where
it's got people performing adult
activities in them which they did have
in schools yeah that that's a little
different you know you know we're not
talking about ideologies I don't like
the idea of banning books because of
their ideology but I don't like the idea
of teaching the ideology and you know
what's funny is even the book burners
don't even really think about that
because they're like oh yeah there's
this the book the marks Marx's book is
in the library Communist Manifesto
that's in the library so is Adam Smith
right nobody cares that they're both in
the library you can't have them both if
you're a book burner you can't have both
those books in the library
but but it's it's all just weapons how
do you explain to uh Zealot you know
what I mean I remember uh my my whole
life there's never been a real issue as
far as I could tell about I mean there's
been some peripheral issues about prayer
in school like oh it shouldn't happen
but most people were like okay Public
Schools shouldn't do that we get it fine
whatever but now you have a new that's a
new thing man but now we have parent
Schools they're just they're just
they're just you know contemplating on
whiteness right which as far as I'm
concerned is no different right well
it's a really fascinating thing to to
see how the woke thing is really a
religion with Sacrament and and and and
ritual and visual representations and
all these things that that Echo uh
religious experiences and what it really
tells me which is something that I have
learned over these last several years is
that uh God man do you need it it's
there you need it there's a hole in us
that needs to be filled and we all yearn
for some sort of understanding of the
universe that makes us not feel
insignificant uh one of the most
incredible things that I've discovered
as I've been reading the Bible and
praying and like trying to understanding
and come to come to some level of faith
is that uh instead of like coming up
with a model of the world to justify my
behaviors or Justify my actions or
perceptions there's like a ready-made
model that unites you with the universe
with Creation with living a good life
with having good outcomes and that is
actually really comforting to know that
the system has been in place for a long
time it works for a lot of people and
when you come across somebody that
really believes and really practices you
can feel that energy come right out of
their face it's incredible I don't think
everyone needs religion or needs God but
I think most people probably need
something like they need
some version of this like of this Faith
system I remember I talked I've talked
to a lot of people about you know like
psychedelics and psilocybin and stuff
like that and they're like man people
really need this stuff and I was like
yeah I don't think I do
um like the people say it's like it's
very good it can open your mind and I'm
like yeah I don't think I need that to
to consider new ideas or or change my
opinions and be open to exploring this
you know maybe that's just me I
personally don't feel like I need to
have any kind of guiding Faith force in
my life that being said I do believe in
God but uh that's why you don't feel any
need for it brother maybe maybe that's
it maybe I you know I guess people who
lack that are lost and scared and
confused yeah because if you think about
it you're just a lump of cells on a
planet in a cold dark infinite Universe
if you really put yourself in that
person it is but if you put yourself
there for no reason and no purpose
randomly by accident well yeah life's
insignificant and you're facing the
infinite infinite but that's that's
purpose that's not God you know what I
mean you couldn't believe in God and
still believe that you have no purpose
so so maybe purpose is a better purpose
and meaning are two different things I
guess huh maybe some people find their
purpose through God and some people have
nothing and so they create purpose and
ideology you know what's interesting is
that mood follows motion activity is
life and the Christians say love thy
neighbor so if you love you're their
neighbor and you act it and you put it
into motion and you become active in
this regard it you you get filled with
the love and energy that makes those
questions go away
you just don't think about it because
you're filled with good energy it's
incredible the cult members hope that
once they Purge people like you and I or
everyone who's watching they will have a
pure Utopia world
because I'll tell you communism
can work it can't Gail it's all about
scale no no but at a very very large
scale of even a billion people communism
can work it's very simple you just have
to kill anyone who opposes them right
exactly and so it literally it means it
doesn't work because you have to kill
everybody but that's why they always do
it because when the Communists gain
power they say what's stopping us from
having everyone March in lockstep like
worker ants it's these free thinking
dissidents yeah my good friend Joe
Norman who is a complexity scientist and
teaches people complexity science you
should check them out Joe Norman he's
been on my podcast Jack Murphy live a
couple of times what he's taught me is
that everything is about scale
everything is about scale one idea can
work at one skill and it won't work at a
different scale in my family it is
communist
from from it's expected that I can
deliver the goods and everybody else
gets what they need according to their
needs and that's beautiful and I love it
it's perfect but as the scale gets
bigger and bigger and bigger you need a
different uh for me forming algorithm or
reforming ideas imagine if someone was
like a car is a tool that can go from
point A to point B I need to move three
you know three thousand pounds of bricks
and I have a car it should work right
it's like no you need a different
vehicle for that process no it's exactly
right so if our goal is to move
resources from person to person on a
small family level yeah it's great
you're you're a commune you're a family
someone's the boss you know there's
varying degrees of who's in charge
depending on what riches you have and
everyone gets what they need but if you
want to move resources in a large scale
civilization you need capitalism
the funny thing is the left doesn't know
what the word capitalism means and I
think that's part of the indoctrination
change definitions and you can confuse
people right so it's funny when you see
leftists complain about communism but
call it capitalism right they complain
about the state controlling resources
and colluding with the powerful Elites
to dictate who gets what and they're
like is capitalism man it's like
capitalism just very plainly means and I
believe capitalism came from Marx anyway
very plainly means the private trade of
goods meaning an individual can trade
freely as they choose period we are not
in a pure capitalist system by the way
not even close yeah we're in it we're in
a very constructed and controlled
economy right well and the government
works to pick winners and losers and
especially pick losers we're feeling
that you can't even work if you don't do
exactly what we say this is an issue for
sure and of course we've evolved into
like an oligarchic State it's corporate
feudalism and you don't even really
really going to own anything which is
what they want private it's interesting
I had the conversation with Alexander
Dugan a Russian philosopher people
called Putin's lap dog whatever he and I
talked about this very issue and he said
that he wants to get rid of capitalism
and I was like well you know you might
not have a lot of fans over here in the
United States if you keep talking about
getting rid of capitalism he's like no
no no
I don't mean get rid of private property
I just mean get rid of what's happened
today what capitalism has turned into
and that got that got my interest a
little bit and you know the guy's a
little crazy and he's got some seriously
out there ideas and you've done some
probably pretty bad things but he was
interesting it's interesting to talk to
because you know he's an influential guy
and I can see how uh inequality the the
concentration of wealth in the hands of
very few people uh leads to to negative
outcomes and and of course we would want
more people to share in the Bounty that
we've created but if you believe in
humanity if you believe in individuals
then you will believe in individual
outcomes and you will believe in
differing outcomes and the founders were
very clear on this different faculties
lead to different outcomes and we need
to preserve that let's talk about Mr
Elon Musk oh my God from CNBC Elon Musk
says he will pay over 11 billion dollars
in taxes this year did you see the
Babylon B interview the day with them I
did I saw a little bit of it where the
guys sitting around interviewing him
were so cringe actually they're like uh
we don't even know why we're talking to
you I was like bro he's there he agreed
you just need to ask questions with
confidence but I didn't see you guys are
cool dudes yeah but uh come on the show
man maybe a little yeah um I treated
Elon once he tweeted at me we're friends
not your friends and together you guys
are going to pay 12 billion in taxes
this year that's right so I'm I'm
disappointed in this I think Elon should
not have done this he did it to make a
point and to try and defang you know
people like Elizabeth Warren which okay
I suppose is still a good thing here's
what here's what I think happened
they've been saying people who are
wealthy should pay taxes on their wealth
the wealth tax so Elon Musk was like
okay should I liquidate my stock and
then pay taxes on it and people were
like do it he said okay I will so he
ends up giving the government 11 billion
dollars in taxes which empowers really
awful people to make a point I suppose I
suppose in that in that uh that's a very
expensive point I think it's really
expensive that you might want to think
that there's a different mode of there I
I got it maybe he's been waiting to
liquidate those assets and this gave him
a good reason to do it
Etc you never know you never know when
he's making tweets about crypto I don't
think he cares about the money you know
there's a certain amount of money where
you don't care but hit but to him money
means Mars money means space money means
advancing the universe just like you
tell me Tim you know you tell me you're
not all about the money what you're all
about is building new things creating
new opportunities starting these
non-profits having a serious impact on
the world you're a philanthropist
already he's a philanthropist and
somebody who's working towards a better
man of society I believe sure sure so
what I was going to say in in the in the
Babylon B interview he talks about how
he came to be worth so much money in the
richest person in the world and he said
he doesn't have the money he started a
company he owns I think what he's doing
20 of the stock or something
and he's like I own 20 of the stock in a
company the investors decided the
company was worth one trillion dollars
so my stock is worth 200 billion dollars
I didn't do anything I don't have any
money they've just decided that and now
you know we get Elizabeth Warren being
like he's not paying any taxes because
she is a despicable person because you
know she knows she sold out Bernie
Sanders and they still they still you
know she understands the difference
between paper investment gains and
actual earned income you know she knows
the difference between these things did
uh did the bill pass that had the clause
in it that said that we were going to be
taxed on unrealized capital gains I
don't think so
because the bill that says that you're
going to be taxed on your mileage driven
that did pass yeah that did pass there's
provision in there to create a pilot
program to test out the best way to tax
people on their mileage driven and the
number that they were tossing around was
insane it was something like eight cents
a mile
that's like 2 000 bucks a year for the
average person Elon basically is coming
out now saying I've paid more taxes in
the than any more taxes than any other
person in history and Elizabeth Warren
doesn't pay taxes but she'll still keep
lying because these people aren't evil
and Elon Musk did this to make a point
but it doesn't matter dude there's a
very interesting analysis to be made of
who where is it for the betterment of
society that the government now has that
11 billion or if Elon Musk had that 11
billion so the The Young Turks had on
Ari the rugged Man to cap after yeah no
yeah and Jank was like looking at the
camera constantly like just trying to
bait me into a drama thing I don't I
don't think like he knows at all who I
am or whatever but so what I decided to
do is I had so many people saying like
you don't need to prove anything Tim you
don't need to respond to them and I'm
like no no hold on
so you know the rugged man comes on the
show and he says my experience has never
happened I'm lying and I'm like I just
find it really funny that like they
admit and acknowledge I am mixed race
they admit and acknowledge he is a white
man and that they agree with him when he
laughs at someone who says I mixed race
and I experience racism I want that net
narrative to persist I'm glad The Young
Turks made that video God those guys are
so trashy so I did I did a video with my
sister
um and I put it up at 1pm on youtube.com
timcast news 40 minutes long where she
we basically talk about you know our
childhood growing up and you know why
why I wanted to address the Young Turks
and I didn't do it to prove any point
necessarily like to them I didn't I
don't need The Young Turks to believe me
I need you to believe me what I mean by
this is
when The Young Turks come out and they
say Temple will lie to mail this stuff
up there will be people watching saying
yeah I wonder if you really did lie make
that stuff up and I'll say okay I will
have my sister on and we will talk about
everything we've been through as
embarrassing as it is for my family and
whatever people end up thinking about us
because I'm telling you the truth and I
want people to then look at the Young
Turks and see how their despicable
racists and I want them to look at me
and my family and say these people are
talking about the true struggles they've
been through the reason I bring that up
is because when people started
commenting and saying like you don't
need to prove anything to them they are
100 correct I didn't do it to prove
anything to The Young Turks I did it so
regular people can see it I kind of feel
like Elon might be doing some of that to
sort of like let people know he's not
that guy you know to use the meme he's
not the dude who's going to exploit
everybody and take all this money and
that he's more interested in going to
space and it just so happens he has his
money I do kind of feel like part of it
though was to prove a point to to to the
Democrats and he gave the government
money which he didn't need to do he did
not need to sell billions of dollars in
stock and then pay the governance money
he could have just kept it in stock and
said I have no reason to take the money
out I mean if he's paying 11 billion
dollars in taxes how much did he
liquidate and how much did he end up in
his pocket yeah you gotta sell a lot of
stuff to pay 11 billion in taxes 11
billion 20 right 20 capital gains or is
a little bit higher yeah I think it's 28
because it might be higher than that it
might be way higher than that because of
Biden it might actually be like 40 or
something like he netted he netted a
good bit you know people need to
understand what a billion dollars is
a thousand Millions you would not be
able to spend it I'm not exaggerating
you would not be able to spend it
people don't get this man there was this
thread well it depends on what you're
doing right because that new Tesla
Factory apparently is like some like 10
000 football fields in size I mean I'm
exaggerating but I think it's something
as insane as that right I don't I don't
think you'd be able to spend it
as an individual consumer yeah
um as an individual so if you if if you
as a business uh are are seeking to
build a factory that's you know a
thousand football fields or whatever
yeah there's going to be way the
logistics and then it's gonna be Way
Beyond one person making a purchase
right this is going to be a massive
undertaking of different companies and
different CEOs an individual would not
be able to spend that money Elon Musk
liquidating this money he's probably
shrugging saying I don't know right
because bro a super yacht what do those
go for like 30 million or something
30 million so what you got 970 million
left like I guess you can buy a 10 of
them
but then you got to maintain them like
it's just there's a certain amount of
wealth where you're sitting there
confused as to what you're even doing
well you have to hire people to figure
out how to spend it yeah yeah I guess
you hire people to figure out how to
manage it you hire people to figure out
how to spend it and then you hire people
to figure out how to defend it and then
where to invest it this is where the
idea of a family office comes in these
people literally have to hire for what
to manage their money well for
philanthropy eventually right I suppose
you know I feel like when you're at the
point where elon's at I wonder why
doesn't Elon take a billion dollars and
say who wants to start a media
organization to go after the fake news
and the liars well I I mean isn't he I
know Peter Thiel at least has used some
of his money to his foundation which is
for Education which is to to produce new
entrepreneurs so you know they're
they're giving pieces back I think maybe
they have different priorities you know
they have different priorities in terms
of what their philanthropy can do and
how it can affect the world for sure
Mark these are smart guys making
calculated decisions there's no question
about that if I had a billion dollars
I would know exactly how to begin
allocating things towards solving a lot
of these problems and so I suppose it's
as simple as Elon Musk wants to go to
Mars he has a he has a different
perspective on what the problems are and
that's something his company has to do
but my point is to be someone like Elon
and know they're lying know the media
lies all the time yeah and to have the
ability to effectively snap your fingers
and challenge that that machine but he
can already do that with Twitter and
social media no no no no no no no no he
can't look how much did Bezos buy The
Washington Post for a couple hundred
million yeah peanuts basically peanuts
well I mean relative to his net worth
yeah Elon Musk could be like I could
fund that three times over and set up
three Washington Post operations that'll
operate indefinitely the guardian
operates off an endowment they just
generate interest off of some all the
money they have that helps fund
everything Elon Musk could literally be
like
okay here's a billion dollars towards
the Babylon B guys hey
you know people who are challenging the
machine you guys make jokes about it all
day figure it out maybe he doesn't see
it as a problem like you do maybe it's
just not on his radar maybe maybe he's
being more efficient with his Capital
allocation who knows maybe you just
can't be everything to everybody why am
I over here carrying waterproof like I
don't I have no dude I like him yeah I
don't think he's perfect I think he does
a lot of dumb stuff but um I think I
think he's a good dude and I think he's
he's genuine he wants to try and he
wants to be honest that's why he's
giving away all he's that's why he
liquidated these assets and is paying
the billions in Texas you know what I
liked about that he did the uh the The
Babylon Bee interview he's like oh well
I read all your stuff
right it's not like he needs to go on
the show to sell anything or to pimp
anything or whatever you know but he
goes on the show because he's like they
they he he quoted back to them their own
headlines I know and and they're like
the one guy was like wow you you know
our content better better than we do and
that's just hilarious to me it really
was actually humanizing maybe he did it
just for fun but maybe it's the same
reason that Northrop men puts
advertisements on Hulu just so that we
all just get accustomed to thinking
Northrop Grumman is a good thing because
I'm not buying f-16s I don't know
someone someone super chatted if I had
elon's money Gundams would be real and
functional yeah do you know the Gundam a
Gundam a Gundam is that like a gun
Kingdom it's a gigantic robot like from
an ad is an anime oh okay the pilots are
in gigantic mechanized you know oh yeah
yeah like Voltron kind of yeah exactly
yeah and uh yes I tweeted at Elon Musk
why haven't you built an Iron Man suit
yet yeah and he responded building
Starship and then I said that is an
acceptable response
because my point was basically like why
aren't you going crazy like you have
you're you're an eccentric dude why
aren't you just being like because it is
time work dude work work is life yo what
if you're me or if you're somebody else
who's working nine to five work is life
get up work hard be tired that is I get
it I get it I get it bro if I had a
billion dollars you know what I would do
I would hire a prank monkey like Mr
Burns yeah you already said Simpsons
episode where he hires Homer as his
prank monkey no and then he like he's
like you know Homer Splash Lenny and
then he does then Mr Burns laughs and
then Homer splashes Carl and goes good
God man that's coral and then he's like
he helps Carl to the chemical watch you
know what I would do I'd hire a prank
monkey what would their job be I'd be
like I want you to just culture Jam buy
Billboards culture Jam buy commercials
do things that shock people out of their
routine I want someone driving down
Sunset Boulevard to see like a billboard
board that is confusing is confusing can
be just weird disruptive confusing stuff
there's kind of like to shake Society by
the shoulders and be like this is nuts
you know what I would do if I had a
billion dollars I would buy every
billboard in Times Square and say
vaccine mandates are wrong
what you know that's interesting uh
thing together does it cost that much
money would they sell them to you
knowing that that's what you're gonna
say did you wear the thoughts have one
did they yeah they did project Veritas
at negative times Time Square thing let
me see if I can remember I do remember
they had a billboard
I don't know did you see the funding
that they achieved for this 22 million
dollars bro that is a good chunk of
change that is a lot of operatives in
the field yeah Veritas has had a Time
Square billboard oh snap yeah covet
gangbusters with the ratings yep Twitter
banned us they can't ban the truth yeah
yeah yeah Money Talks baby maybe maybe
some of them wouldn't but you could do
so much to change the world for the
better if you had this money and they
don't do it but you sir are doing it bit
by bit with it they do that they do do
it and they do do all over it Mackenzie
Bezos putting billions of dollars into
critical race Theory right yeah it's
just the problem is even Jack yep that's
right he funded that that Academy or
something Jack Dorsey funded Ibrahim
candy yep to the tune of millions and
millions and millions of dollars and
that means that means Jack Dorsey is on
the wrong side Jack dorsey's Evil Jack
Dorsey is trying to lead America off the
cliff he's trying well I think what you
basically have is a really dumb guy Jack
yeah it was like leading people towards
their destruction thinking he's helping
oh you know
um I don't I don't mean like I I guess I
I guess that's a little bit too dumb guy
come on ignorant ignorant they're hero
big difference that's what I was saying
a little a little too low brow a little
too blunt
um I I think in a lot of ways he's a
smart dude you know he's started Twitter
and he started a square and they're very
successful squares one of the most
successful um you know Financial
processing companies yeah but um to be
as blind and ignorant in politics and to
fund this evil like come on you know Dom
might be a little blunt but it's a
little emotional too yeah where's
where's Peter Thiel and Elon Musk doing
the inverse
Elon Musk goes in the Babylon B okay
Elon dude give the Babylon B guys like
100 million bucks I think I think Peter
does a lot of stuff behind the scenes
sure you know I think he funds things he
pushes agendas he's got he I think he's
more Savvy in this regard uh than than
Elon than uh than Jack for sure but you
know Elon Musk give the Babylon B 100
million dollars but look but look but
look we're we're suffering from the same
problem that a lot of people have which
is like why won't that guy do something
the thing is is that you're already
doing something I'm not diminishing a
million dollars I'm doing what I can do
everybody needs to do what they can do
they have to do their little part they
have to do their medium part they have
to do their big part and we can't just
sit around and be like well why doesn't
the trillionaire do it and and that's
not you and that's not me and that's not
the people that we know but I just you
know I think it's very easy for people
to take the position of like well why
isn't he doing it when is the savior
gonna come when is the daddy figure
gonna come fix everything for us
you have to as Ronald Reagan said all
meaningful change positive change in
America starts at the dining room table
I get it and that's where we have to
start I I agree but what I mean is so
we're certainly doing stuff we've got
two foundations we've got the technology
Foundation which is the on Foundation
which is building Tech we've got an
alpha that's in production which will
create a decentralized social media
system it will effectively effectively
give everyone a snap of a finger
subscription website that interlinks
with other websites so you'll never be
banned that you you go on patreon you
get banned you go on locals you can get
banned you go any one of these platforms
you get banned if you own the space if
you own the the domains and own all that
they have to ban you one at a time the
domain house has to remove your domain
the server company has to kick off the
servers you know all those things have
to have your Cloud you know uh storage
if you have all of these decentralized
it's harder to remove you and you can
even own the servers in your own home
that's the one thing we're doing all we
also have the truth and media Foundation
which is going to be a fact-checking
website and we are going to fact check
all of these deceptive and manipulative
news articles they say oh we're trying
to stop misinformation like well we're
going to do that we're actually going to
do it and it's and we're going to track
and we're going to we're going to label
these companies that's something that I
can do and it's not easy to do it's been
very expensive filing all the stuff that
dedicating all the hours to doing the
paperwork to running two different
non-profits massive and I don't have a
billion dollars no that's what is what
I'm saying
as this company grows and more and more
people become members at timcast.com and
support our work that those funds are
being allocated towards expanding the
work we do
so like what's what what's the expense
that we have like we we have all these
members we're making money I'm building
a a production facility in West Virginia
that's going to do multiple things one
of the reasons why I want to do West
Virginia Freedom one of the other
reasons I want to do West Virginia I
want to bring good jobs to the area I
want to help people in the area I want
to improve the economy and West Virginia
is one of the poorest states in the
country so I thought this is an
excellent opportunity because you've got
good land you've got good people you've
got freedom we've got people who share
values and we can Empower this in more
ways than just having a news company one
of the ways to empower our ideals is to
make sure there are good jobs and a good
economy for the people who agree with us
on our ideals so for every dollar I put
in to this area that dollar goes to a
contractor who you know who lays
concrete he spends that dollar at the
local burger shop for lunch the burger
shop then gets to hire a contractor to
fix their building all of that stays in
circulates in that economy and I want to
bring that economy out here that's
awesome Tim I remember on our very first
time when I was first guest on the show
back in February 2020 I brought up my
dream of having a building a village 80
acres with a river with a canal through
it that's all you need you could put
tens of thousands of people there and uh
dude kudos to you for like really
pushing that ball forward we've been
looking at land in West Virginia and
Southwestern Virginia and uh trying to
move things forward my time my timeline
is is a little slower than yours because
my kids and proximity and all that but
there's there's a nice work bro there's
there's like a hundred acres for you
know like 300 Grand yeah it's I'm not
going to pretend like for the average
person they can just snap their fingers
and do it but if if you can get the loan
do you know the mortgage your property
my issue my issue isn't like the act of
acquiring the land it's like is it time
for me to start tilling the land right
because uh I've got young kids and we've
got kids in school and I'm tied to the
area and I want to be with them I'm
hugely invested in their lives and being
there every single day it's just not
time for me to move to West Virginia and
start tilling the land in every which
way the info away and Building Things
and such but but it is where I want to
be and my background's in real estate
development too so like this is like
right in my wheelhouse so so to kind of
put a bow on what we were talking about
my main point is we we do not have the
level of resources anywhere near 99 of
even other media companies like you know
uh you you look at some of these
traditional media Outlets Fox News they
have a skyscraper
they have all this money you know what
are they really doing they just rolled
it a vax mandate for for all of their
employees and people are like but New
York's making them doing oh BS Fox News
could say screw off we got more lawyers
than you do come at us and the city
would be like are we gonna go to war
with fox fox doesn't care Fox bends the
knee so when I when I when I'm pushing
the limit as hard as possible you know
what I could be doing and what everyone
tells me I should be doing when we have
money come in in profits they're like
you got to put it away you got to hire a
money manager invest for your future Tim
invest for your future because you're
not going to work forever and I'm like I
want to invest in things they're gonna
have a long-standing impact for everyone
so you know when we built this building
this facility I'll say
the improvements we do on it for
actually this building for instance that
we you know we have a loan on it of
course the improvements we've done have
made it less likely to be sold yeah of
course you put in a skate park in the
basement well we want to we want to be
exciting we want to inspire young people
yeah we want to make it a fun cool place
to be right we want everything we do to
be right that's a loss that's a loss for
you right like so for example Jack
brunch I have made money I want to see I
wanted a skate park bro I mean I like on
Jack brunch I made one I made money off
of one because we had a sponsor a
platinum sponsor every other single Jack
brunch no the fact even though we had 80
90 people at each one they're all losses
for me yeah because I wanted to deliver
more than I was willing to ask from
people I'm talking thousands and
thousands of dollars we lost because we
put out these massive spreads bottomless
drinks I mean man we just wanted to make
the thing happen right and so I
understand this like sense to give back
and in fact we all should be giving back
charity is a value we should be doing
and if it doesn't hurt as it's not
enough well it's it's I want to plant
trees that's it and that's I that's what
the tour was about no no check it out
you know the saying goes Society grows
great when you know men plant trees
whose shade they know they will never
sit beneath a person plants trees that's
right no only men only men only men
um but there's buildings that we're
putting together it's going to be fun
for us yeah we're gonna have a good time
there where one of the reasons we want
to do this is because we want to be in
West Virginia like I said you know
building an economy and expanding but
also creating a a an easy way to invite
people out we wanted to do it here we
were like in March hey we're gonna have
events here we couldn't do it we we
tried we tried it we tried and it was
just like your risk assessment is 89 and
we are getting denied insurance and all
this stuff with the new building we
don't have to worry about any of that
gotcha and so this is like okay we're
gonna once a week we're gonna have like
a reservation list where you can choose
you know as a member you can come out
and and come hang out at the studio and
be involved and get to meet everybody
and it's going to be this big building
it's going to be amazing 20 25 foot
walls 36 foot ceiling you're gonna be
hanging out with a big projector screen
you're gonna be able to see us in the
studio through the big glass window we
are building this stuff because we want
to inspire people and make sure our
ideas are you know the seat is planted
and they flourish
it's not so much about just giving back
it's about we get to enjoy what we do
and the fruits of our labor but we're
going to leave something behind for
everyone else too that's that's one of
the reasons I think West Virginia is so
important if I were to set this business
up in New Jersey and then 50 years from
now I'm dead or whatever who in New
Jersey would inherit that and what would
they do with it they'd become like Fox
News they would be like we are
challenging them the establishment what
was that establishment you want us to
implement a vax mandate you got it boss
now in West Virginia for at least the
time being people are going to be like
get away from us freedom right West
Virginia beautiful country I'm headed
there in just a couple of weeks for the
holidays love it
love it West Virginia yeah good for you
Tim it's better weather than look
everybody's moving to Florida or Texas
and I'm like man but the weather Florida
Texas and Tennessee that's what I keep
hearing guys in the Lo have been
flocking to Tennessee moving Tennessee's
all right from from New York from
Portland from all over the country to
Tennessee it's beautiful man but I gotta
I gotta tell you man
um I think Florida and Texas I just
think it's a mistake
they're over developed we looked at I
was thinking about getting a small
property in Texas and creating an Austin
Hub because there's so much activity
going on with people moving there and I
looked at all the buildings and I looked
at the cities and I was like this is not
a good idea it's not it's just another
hipster location it would be like moving
to Williamsburg in 2011. right that's
exactly right and that's the vibe I got
no offense Nashville no offense Austin
but that was that was the vibe I got and
they're on they're on a path to not
being what want made me want to go there
in the first place but one of the things
I was most struck by in Tennessee was
going to like the state capitol and
going to monuments and stuff and I live
in DC a federal district with like
pretty limited history go to a state
like Tennessee and you're at this
capital and you're at the The Monuments
and you're like all these people they
went and they died in these wars and all
their pride that they have and like man
that was actually really uh intriguing
and sort of romantic for me I can't wait
to get out of DC man I can't wait yeah I
think about about West Virginia
and this big empty property and I'm like
you know I talk about how the the the
colonists come to North America and they
they land on a Barren Shore and they're
like all right you know 20 of the people
on this boat have died already from the
trip now we're all going to start
building on the shoreline and another 20
of you are going to die and they
basically come across undeveloped space
I'm like we've got to build houses we
gotta start farming we got to figure out
how to survive and they did it so I'm
like man for the past several years I've
been thinking I don't want to go to a
developed Hub like Miami just because
everyone's there I'm like that's easy I
don't want to go to Florida because they
they have been you know passing the
right laws and everything and go to go
to a place that someone else has done
the hard work to make great I want to go
to somewhere where I have the freedom to
make something great truth be told it is
better laws in West Virginia because
people were voting for good for better
laws but there are a lot of people who
need industry there some of the poorest
people in the country live in West
Virginia
we're going to change this in 50 years
there is going to be an economic
Powerhouse out of West Virginia and
they're going to have very libertarian
values and they're imagine this the
might of the New York Times
headquartered in rural West Virginia
all of a sudden because this is what
people need to understand just dream big
Timmy oh I'm not even done dreaming the
reason why the media is overwhelmingly
left is because they put all the
headquarters in big cities which are
Democrat run the only people who can get
jobs there are wealthy Dem are wealthy
Democrat children whose parents
subsidize them to live in places like
New York City indeed then you end up
with 97 of all media coming from from
leftist you know activists and and world
view oligarch's gonna oligarch but what
happens when you get a giant skyscraper
for some reason in rural West Virginia
surrounded by nothing and the people who
work there are all like regular these
are people with backgrounds and blue
collar jobs and Tradesmen and they have
kids who can afford to live in the area
who grew up working on a farm who
started you know learning how to write
or report or do videos and then they
come and work at a media worker people
are going to call you a gentrifier to me
they can call me whatever I want that's
a that that's a CRT uh leftist
propaganda I don't care about that the
people who live there are going to be
like look the the people will attract
for these jobs who live in the area are
going to be alike I worked with my hands
I know what A Hard Day's Work really
means
and then they're going to be those
values will be coming out of that
broadcast tower I don't really think
we'll build a skyscraper because I think
skyscrapers aren't practical but we're
gonna we're talking about finding an old
like decaying City and just buying up
property and renovating and then
expanding totally and you should do that
also in a place where that you can also
run people for uh County Executive Board
and sheriff and have your own police and
legislature and school system I mean
yeah I'm not I'm not a big fan of
politics but I recognize if we don't do
that bad people will come in I have
spent time researching counties that
have a small enough population where I
feel like we could bring enough people
to move in there to take over the the
Sheriff's Office and the school system
uh in order to ensure uh that our values
and our beliefs are propagated and you
know uh it was a
um I was gonna say wild wild country is
that what it is a documentary about the
the I wanna cult is a loose word but
they they they did that Wild Wild West
Virginia no no that's that was separate
white and wild is a different
documentary about West Virginia no this
was a about a cult leader an Indian guy
and they bought up all this property in
some area and then they tried to take
over the the council the local board and
all the real estate there caused quite a
hubbub from the locals for sure but you
know that is that that's representative
representational government if you own
the land and you live there and your
people live there and you vote for the
thing that's the way it's supposed to be
so do it man yeah we're doing it I know
you are it's great let's let's just do
one more segment before we go to super
Chats on The Matrix so uh The Matrix
came out today and I watched it maybe I
need to get another drink and it was
conservative propaganda I was triggered
I was where did you did you go to a
theater no I just watched it on HBO Max
oh gosh it was conservative propaganda
what I was triggered what and I was
screaming but I was at it I was at an
impasse I didn't know who to complain to
to get it banned so
um no but in all seriousness I'm only
half kidding I don't want to spoil the
movie for people want to see it but a
large component of the film I believe
maybe it was unintentional but it kind
of
casts the left as like
bad how I'd have to spoil the film to
explain oh man yep how are we gonna
review this it an element of the film
expresses leftist ideas from the
villain's perspective
and in the end and the end of the film
they outright tell regular people to
like take the red pill
like no joke and a core element of the
film is the power of a traditional
family
beautiful not kidding that's that's
absolutely and and did anything I'm
going to say one one thing yeah that
will spoil that may spoil some of the
film spoiler alert so you have been
warned you have been warned I'm saying
it one more time I am going to say an
element of the film which I believe will
spoil a part of the film I'm not going
to give you a plot point I'm not going
to explain what Neo does or why he's
doing what he does but I will just say
this okay now that you've been warned
sufficiently a core element of the film
is that they're they're in order in
order for Humanity to exist there needs
to be a matriarch and a patriarch there
needs to be a man and woman working
together wait I thought men and women
were exactly the same dude not in this
way I thought that actually you could
change from being a man into a woman
isn't that
isn't that the Matrix was really about
initially you really think that that was
what it was about originally come on I
mean like the guys that character switch
in the film yeah was actually in the
film right you know the character switch
was right sure trans person I understand
that but the the creators they're trans
yes yes uh and but wasn't it sort of
backward mapped onto the Matrix later
that the the real intent behind the
movie was to like extol trans virtues I
wouldn't know uh so here's what they say
about that in the uh the first word that
I think appears in the film is trans it
says trans system operator or something
like that really yeah and then there's
um it says system failure and you go
between M and F the film Zooms in
between MF do you think there's
continuity from the very first one to
this one all outplanned like for example
lost absolutely remember the series
I just wonder if they planned it all out
from the beginning the estrogen pills in
the 90s were red pills
really and so apparently they were
saying take the red pill was take a
estrogen pill take the estrogen pill you
hear that manosphere you hear that
manosphere y'all been y'all been eating
estrogen pills this entire time oh my
goodness holy cow I knew there was
something up with those guys
so this is from a year ago the red pill
died
the Newsweek The Matrix Creator explains
the red pill really isn't men's rights
activists aren't going to be happy and
they they go and explain there's a
picture of it I think somewhere okay
there's not they're talking about in the
uh in the 90s
the the the pill they would take to
transition was a red pill let me see if
I can find that is absolutely hilarious
really funny sweet Justice yeah uh
Premarin
oh yeah is that yeah estrogen it's red
pills imagine if you built your whole
brand about Brown being red pilled and
it turns out that it actually meant
eating estrogen wow
no wonder you're a bee now I don't know
if like so some of these things can just
be coincidences and they and they did
they they you know they backed attached
it or whatever but uh that's what they
say I'll tell you this
um is the zoom in between the m and the
F things Is that real it's real yeah and
that that's exactly annuity system
failure and there's an m at the end of
system and an f and you and it zooms in
past them and the first word in the film
it says trans system operator or
something like that that could I I
believe when I saw that I was like what
does that mean trans system operator
like what is it I think it's trans to my
I'm not entirely sure but we watched it
again like a couple weeks ago we watched
all three Matrix movies because like the
new movie's coming out we're gonna watch
it the first one's real good the
character switch in the first Matrix you
know the character switch is what was
supposed to be a person who goes in The
Matrix and their residual self-image was
female and then in the real world they
were male or something and according to
the story The Studio thought it was too
you know weird for regular people they
wouldn't they wouldn't like it I
actually think that's a that's a good
idea for a film like if if the idea of
the Matrix is you have an identity and
when you go in you become an identity
the only issue is I think people should
turn into giraffes too you know what I
mean like furries would turn into Bugs
Bunny and stuff like that but but that's
an interesting concept for a matrix
because we're going to see that with the
metaverse but I'll say this you've
already seen it in fortnite
there's little boys acting as with
female characters and nobody actually
well even every game though I know but
nobody like nobody even blinks tonight
so why in the metaverse would it be any
different why why would you blink an eye
here's the thing about the Matrix
resurrections I don't think it has
anything to do with the Matrix at all
like the themes of the original Matrix
do not translate into this movie I'm
like it's an entirely different movie
they just call it Matrix oh I see yeah I
mean there's there's uh I'll say a few
things the film is uh hates itself
not exaggerating they self-reference
themselves how much they hate making
this what the heck no joke like in the
movie they basically say this is garbage
we don't want to do it we don't want to
make this were they contractually
obligated
um I'm gonna I'm gonna go further into
spoilers now for some of you guys so now
I'll get into some direct a direct
spoiler uh it's not a plot point it's
just uh it's part of the early part of
it's part of the early movie I think the
first half an hour of the movie was
intended to insult and deride Warner
Brothers
and then the movie starts okay sure so
uh I'll explain
in the film spoiler warning again
because I really really want to make
because I'm gonna actually give a hard
spoiler
uh Neo is a game developer
he made a game called The Matrix
and he's sitting down with his business
partner and his business partner goes
our parent company Warner Brothers has
insisted we do a sequel none of us want
to do it but they said if we don't do it
they'll do it without us oh man so they
were basically looking into the camera
yeah
saying it outright and so the in the
movie it's that they made a video game
called The Matrix the Warner Brothers
wants a new Matrix Game and they don't
want to make it but they have no choice
because either they do it or it gets
remade like trash
so they said fine we'll be involved and
that's the Stu I'm watching the women
like this is so dumb the first half an
hour is literally them being like they
made us do it we don't like it don't be
mad at us that's that's kind of
seinfeldy there is literally a scripted
line that says our parent company Warner
Brothers expects a sequel
that's literally in the film gotcha and
then there's it's in the trailer
actually not that part but it's where
the guy goes to be going back to what
all began back to the Matrix you've seen
that in the trailer yeah that's when
he's like they're making us redo this
and we don't want to
but the film uh I gotta say like
the left will probably never admit it
but I don't know how else you explain it
that the movie is literally not that
we're in spoiler mode
it's literally uh they're like Neo and
Trinity as a man and a woman and they're
yearning they have for each other is
what stabilizes the Matrix and without
them as the patriarch and The Matriarch
the new Matrix will collapse that's the
plot
get out there and get married guys yeah
okay the answer and guess what happens
at the end because I'm gonna give you
the big spoiler oh boy here we go
so Neo isn't just the one Trinity also
is the one is the two of them together
so in the original film Neo is the the
the patriarch who fights and saves
everybody and and Trinity is just the
Damsel in Distress
in this one they both have superpowers
I I was shocked by this the villain at
the end says to them we we will never
give up because people don't want to be
free they don't want the truth they
don't want to be empowered they want to
embrace their feelings over facts and
then Neo and Trinity are like we're
gonna change this world we're not here
to negotiate and I was just like
what like that doesn't sound like
leftist it sounds like they're
conservatives right uh fostering uh
human connection the difference between
men and women the fact that they need to
come together they make fun of binary
over and over and over again like but so
but but like it's it's it's it's weird
because
they don't they they make fun of like
the leftist concept of it I I it's it's
it like they acknowledge it it's a real
thing I'm gonna have to worry I showed
my kids this movie they did not
understand the first one but hold on
hold on here's what I think Elena
Wachowski trans Woman made this film
yeah but older trans woman younger
younger trans people are the gender
non-binary people what do you mean like
Camille poglia style trans like she's a
trans woman she's trans but she's a
lesbian no she's said specifically I am
trans Camille Paglia yes are you sure
fat 100 100 but she's the most based
philosopher of all time love her to
death she's great yeah
so you look at like
um Contra points I think I think talked
about this before that older trans
people believe men and women are the
binary and that that's why they're trans
why they transition but younger trans
people say it's there's a million
identities you can be whatever from
whatever part of the spectrum
I wonder if that's really you know like
Lena machowski is like an old school
trans yeah who's like there is a binary
and and they acknowledge that and that's
important to them trans exclusive
radical trans
[Laughter]
exclusionary radical trans women I love
it all right we're gonna go to Super
Chips is it time is it time for super
chats it is time for Super Chat so smash
that like hold on let me call my boy
Matt real quick oh snap subscribe to the
channel uh like the like the like button
smash the like button go to timcast.com
become a member We're not gonna have a
members only segment today because um
we're gonna be getting ready I gotta
pack Friday this is like a half day at
school because it's Christmas Vacation
yes yeah but I do want to say like so
the super chats have been absolutely
inundated with people who are not who
don't like you yeah I imagine so and a
lot of people are saying things like you
know uh you know you should have yelled
at Sydney and all that stuff and so
we'll we'll talk about that right now
but I do want to say one thing too
because a lot of people who are saying
things like I can't believe I believed
in Jack or whatever and Jack's a fraud
and I'm just like guys
we're going to address all those issues
but if if your complaint is about an
article that Jack wrote seven years ago
and you're now saying that like you no
longer like him because of something he
did in the past I don't care if it's a
leftist who does it I don't care if it's
a right winger who does it if someone
did something in the past and they're
like yeah I don't I don't think those
things anymore or I never or I didn't I
don't like that I did that I'm like okay
forgiveness granted thank you for
joining us in the fight for Freedom yes
if we're going to excise our own allies
because of things they did in the past
well you might as well be you know in
the in cancel culture mode or whatever
not that I mean some people should
desire to be canceled and some people
should have to answer for what they did
and all this stuff
but uh I mean should we just do you want
to outright mention the you are here
thing or whatever oh well just on just
on that that one point like why was it
so jarring for people to read that
article about me because I don't ever
talk about it because I don't ever push
those ideas because it's not a part of
my life right it was something that I
wrote uh when I had like a hundred
Twitter followers and I was using a fake
name Jack Murphy is not my real name
everybody spoiler alert my real name is
John Murphy Goldman my grandfather's
name was John Murphy everybody called
him jack so I picked Jack Murphy as a
pseudonym and I wrote an article about
like one element of my sex life all
those years ago that was meant to be
seen by basically nobody and I deleted
it like a few months later and now for
years people have been digging through
my internet trash to like bring it up
and to wave it in my face and the only
reason people are waving at my face is
because we're having a good impact on
society we're like doing good we're
spreading good out there and if it felt
jarring to you to to read this one thing
well yeah that's because I don't talk
about it and it's not something I'm
pushing and it's not something I
advocate after I got divorced dude we
decided we we had fun man we did a lot
of kinky and crazy things and I don't
write about it and I don't talk about it
anymore Joey salads hired black men to
vandalize a car with Trump stickers in
it he staged the whole thing and I
forgave him and had him on the show
several times yeah well I didn't do
anything that stupid I was just I was
just having fun with a girl that I just
started dating we were just going out
and having a good time and I wrote about
it anonymously then I deleted it and now
I have gone through a whole many years
of growth and transformation and reading
and studying and everything that I have
said before up till this point is 100
accurate what but people don't interrupt
me well people are mad at you for
yelling it I I I oh they're like oh we
can talk about that yeah yeah sure I
think they're using a lot of people
don't like the article a lot of people
are using that because they're mad at
you but I think the anger comes from you
yelling at Sydney right so here's what
happened with Sydney so I'm sitting on
the show and we're talking and they're
joking about reading super chats where
people are building like gas Chambers
and she's reading out loud like why how
did I build this gas chamber that didn't
kill all the Jews that I was supposed to
kill right it's like insane the the
super chats that she reads and so I'm
telling her this whole time I'm like hey
you might want to read all the super
chats before you read them out loud
right a little bit of a warning and then
uh she asked me the question about the
article and I answered it politely I
deflected I was like that's not me it's
a 180 degrees from whatever that article
says and I'd really rather not talk
about it anymore
and then a couple minutes later she
literally asked me the same question all
over again and I I cursed at her I
shouldn't have cursed at her and I
apologize Sydney I apologize to her that
day and that night and the next day and
she accepted my apologies so I don't
know why everybody's still butt hurt but
uh I shouldn't have cursed at her I
should have just used amused Mastery and
just like laughed at her and dismissed
her but I didn't because I had set a
boundary and she crossed it and that's
part of being a Man Too is saying here's
my boundary please don't cross it and
then she crossed it and I told her that
I didn't like it did I use the right
words no should I have cursed at her no
and did I apologize to her for that yes
did she apologize to me for putting me
in a bad spot yes did Elijah yes did
Elijah and I go out for dinner and
drinks afterwards yes has Sydney and I
talked afterwards yes so I don't
understand why everybody's so so white
knighting simping for her
she can stand up for herself it's
resolved and in my mind it's done and to
me this is such a nothing Burger in my
life I am so focused on so many other
bigger more important things that uh
people chipping and chirping away at me
at this are just so annoying when I
block people it's because you're
annoying dude it's because you have we
have it
we have to be more than drama right
there are a lot of drama channels I
don't engage with them there is there's
there and and I'm I'm aware and I
mentioned this last week the the one way
to really piss me off is to send me a
video about people saying things about
me yeah because I'm like dude I don't
care about me like what I mean what I
mean by that is like I don't care if you
know so I Saw The Young Turks thing
where jenk was like he's literally
looking into the camera saying over and
over again I'm laughing at you Tim Poole
I'm like I'm like okay dude like
whatever man I did a video
addressing the are the rugged Man thing
got 500 000 views The Young Turks who
did their video got 50 000 views I don't
I don't I'm not saying that bring that
up to be like haha I got more views than
you I'm saying when you focus on the
work when you focus on the ideas when
you are talking about what makes the
world a better place and what we need to
work on
people are interested yeah people are
interested in like what can I do to
better my life yeah but Jank yogurt and
Anna kasparian just insulting me doesn't
improve anyone's life in any way and
doesn't provide them with tools to make
for a better world no and if you're out
there and you're listening to rage
merchants and all they're doing is
stirring up drama and you're just
getting angry enough that you seek out
my email address and my Instagram and my
YouTube and my Twitter and my personal
phone number and my girlfriend who soon
to be my wife and you blowing us up with
all this nastiness like you dude you're
being misled right the idea and
everything that we're working on here is
to help men is to help their families is
to help their community and their Nation
on the way up here today just let me
finish on their way on the way up here
today I had a phone call with one of the
Lo guys and we're talking about this
business that they started that's
literally going to change change the
world it's going to change the world it
is going to transform the world and this
is what we're working on so I'm driving
up here and I'm talking to this guy
about literally changing the world and
now we're talking about this thing that
literally has no relevance in my life
whatsoever at all today and you know
it's kind of annoying but like I I'm
just so over it and not interested in
talking about it which is why I was like
please let's just not talk about it
anymore and uh she wanted to so hey but
I'll tell you this some of these super
chats are funny but I think you even
rolled with the jokes about calling your
boy Matt and stuff like that yeah you
get it sometimes you just gotta you know
it's like whatever dude I have a kinky
pass really I'm really terribly sorry
about it and then and then and then and
then my girl and I we got serious and
now we settle down and now we're getting
married and we're gonna have a nice
traditional life with the kids in the
family and the whole thing like kill me
like come on guys get a grip let's read
some stuff uh wait wait let's read some
super chants stairs into space gaming
says daily wire just announced scotus is
going to hear their vax mandate
arguments yes I encourage everybody to
stop watching Fox News
start watching The Daily Wire yeah stop
sharing Fox News articles if the daily
wire has an article saying the same
thing share that one instead because Fox
News Institute of Vex mandate and
there's no excuse for it oh but we're in
New York and we have to you know there's
a federal mandate that has been
reinstated and the daily wire is going
to be hit by that and they said no the
entire time Fox News had a daily testing
requirement
and where where is Tucker where's Jesse
Waters where's any one of these hosts to
be like we don't agree with this
Ben Shapiro's putting his business on
the line all these guys at the daily
wire doing that I have respect for them
yeah I have a lot of respect for Ben I
remember watching him just sort of
growing up over uh Breitbart back in the
day like 2014 and 15 and he's man that
guy is doing things and he's going for
it and he's putting himself out there I
like it yeah Lori MC says I am watching
The Matrix I turned it off to watch you
live I think I better watch you later
don't spoil the movie for me Merry
Christmas oopsie Daisy but that's why we
gave a really a good warning right
we gave a good warning
all right let's see PM says pretend to
take a shot of malort at Kuma's Corner
for me when you go back to Chicago Merry
Christmas to all of you oh my God I'm
not going anywhere dude dude when I when
I was here the other day you ordered a
box of mallort from Chicago no no
Allison went picked it up was it yeah Oh
I thought it came in shipped and then
when I showed up for the show that night
we all took shots of malort and dude
that stuff is bad
yeah it's a it's a prank apparently
gross all right let's grab some super
chats here
um a lot of a lot of the people a lot of
the super chats we got about you know
the Sydney Elijah thing are people
genuinely being like I don't understand
what that was what happened what
happened with with Sydney yeah they're
like what happened with that what
happened but we addressed it well yeah
you know when the clip people clipped it
where all they see is me me saying you
know cursing at her but they didn't see
the whole thing where I was like let's
not talk about that after I've addressed
it and then she brought it up again so
you know it stinks and it and I and I
wish it didn't happen uh and Sydney and
I are cool and we will be cool and
Elijah's already talked to me about
coming back on the show in February and
I'll happily do that and uh I just think
everybody here should just sort of put
this thing behind them and let's move on
Heathen Airsoft and and Jay says we
don't do drama you just had a whole
segment today about drama between Young
Turks Ari the rugged Man and you no
that's actually not it I don't know if
you watched it or not
um the reason why I did that segment was
because the ideas were really important
and The Young Turks gave me an excellent
opportunity to show you what the left
and progressives are like I said I don't
care that you know The Young Turks want
to laugh at me or make fun of me but I
think it's important that when you have
a regular person who's sitting there
saying like who's right who's a good
person is Tim Poole a good person are
The Young Turks good people I I want a
certain kind of person to watch this
show if you're the kind of person that
thinks insulting and making fun of
people and spending your days involved
in laughing and screaming in people's
faces for tribal points this show is
probably not for you have you read your
comments to me well I don't think these
are our regular viewers our regular
viewers are fairly you know well read
and they often correct us on things
right the goal of that segment was
they're going to be a lot of people who
may be roped into the lies of these
these people grifters now The Young
Turks would like to call me a grifter
many leftists would I will lay out my
entire past with a family member for all
embarrassment and for all of the bad so
that you can know this is who I am and
this is why I believe what I believe
The Young Turks can laugh at me and say
I'm a liar and a racist all day and
night but they have no substantive
argument
I don't care for the drama between The
Young Turks I invited them on the show I
think it'd be great I think the bigger
issue is letting regular people know
here's the people who aren't laughing in
your face and here's the people who are
if you're a working class person on the
south side of Chicago my story properly
related if you're a mixed race person I
get it all the time they're like man
I've been through what you've been
through Tim that resonates with me then
if you have progressives saying you know
we're the ones who are fighting for you
but don't worry if you ever challenge us
we'll laugh in your faces I want as many
people as possible to see that
there's nothing to do with interpersonal
drama it has everything to do with
proving who is like who is actually
fighting the good fight and who is
trying to grift off of you look and Tim
I feel the same way and one of the
reasons that I am kind of happy that
we're talking about this old article and
like my hedonistic past and the fact
that I used to try to just pleasure seek
I was just pleasure seeking is because
ultimately at the end of the day that's
not enough like you're not going to be
satisfied and believe me I have tried
you're not going to be satisfied by that
kind of stuff you need to find a higher
calling and I am happy to be the guy
that leads people who once leave the
hedonistic lifestyle who are looking for
something more important who are looking
for something that means more to them
that's going to return a higher utility
to them as a person and is going to
benefit the nation as a whole so if this
is if if this is my you know thing to
Bear okay fine but like listen to my
content now and understand where we're
going because I've moved past that and
I'm on to something that's really good
and if you want to be onto something
really good let's go all right we got
ghost Crusader says Tim I had to get my
first shot today I live in New York City
I had to I'm the caretaker for my
grandfather and grandmother he has
dementia and she does not want anyone
else but me to take care of him I'd
rather move but I couldn't and that's
how they get you that's hard they they
know they can use your family against
you to enforce this stuff and It
ultimately results in everyone's
suffering because of it it is very hard
people are having to make a lot of tough
decisions Prudence Prudence is never
easy it's by definition hard if you find
yourself in that position I give kudos
to you and please just take some support
understanding there's a lot of us in the
same spot and you're not a bad person if
you make a Prudential decision you're
not all right Dee Thompson says love
your show started watching nightly a few
months ago just finished reading the
fourth turning and wow crazy accurate
for being written in 1996 right another
Playbook like 1984 right and MIT said
that collapse is happening in what 20 40
or something right yeah 80 years 80 to
90 year Cycles yep yep
all right just long enough for everybody
forget about how stupid the last one was
that's how it happened right even
Lincoln was talking about that when
everybody was involved in a revolution
that died no one understood why they
were there they didn't understand the
pain and the suffering everyone went
through memories are short despite the
history books yeah
puddle says hey Tim would you have a
live cast with your family and friends
that you grew up with sharing Old
Chicago stories Lydia is a soldier re
um yeah actually maybe I haven't talked
to the guys from Chicago in Forever
there's there's a couple guys that I'm
friends with on on Facebook that were
like really good friends of mine when I
was like 16 to like 20. and so I keep in
touch with with with with this group of
people
relatively I don't actually talk to them
very frequently but I'm like there's
very few people I'd be like hey come
come out and hang out but um you know my
friend Andy I'd hit him up and invite
him out here any day we got a skate park
Andy come skate I I don't have his
Instagram anymore I haven't seen him in
men I don't know 15 years maybe longer
than that man maybe it's been a lot
longer than that but I'd love to have
these guys out we could do like uh um
something on the website where it's just
like we all talk about Chicago and stuff
like that because those stories are
really fascinating yeah and like when I
got shot at randomly and the the more
you can connect to other people's
experiences the more powerful it is to
spread your message and to get people on
the right track man do it talk about as
much as you can be as open and honest
and authentic as you can why because
look at the guys on CNN is Don Lemon
authentic are the Kumo guys authentic is
Jake Tapper authentic is whatever that
chick is with the short hair and the
glasses on MSNBC is she authentic no
they're not worth listening to
all right Dragon Lady says Lori
Lightfoot and other politicians make a
really big assumption that I want to go
to bars and restaurants Tim that was a
fantastic impression most important no
the Beetlejuice that's so good I just
want to wish you all a very Merry
Christmas you're good people and you
deserve it I haven't seen Beetlejuice in
a very long time but it was great
Michael Keaton the dog they also kind of
talked it's also similar to um
Edgar from Men In Black yeah that's who
I was thinking I was thinking to like I
haven't seen either of those movies
lately maybe I should introduce my my
children to those oh my gosh Men In
Black I like men in black basically
don't feed your kids any content created
after the year 2000 yes the only TV that
I let my daughter my youngest daughter
watch is Fresh Prince of Bel-Air always
a great story in there uh and uh oh man
I forgot the other one off the top of my
head oh the nanny that's just that stuff
is funny The Nanny darn sorry that's
funny and it's based it's based the 90s
were based I love them here we go
Nicholas Lund says Tim rather than using
their language shouldn't we call them
covet inquisitors rather than
investigators yes Austra is hiring
inquisitors someone had a good idea they
said
um a good idea for our shirt was no one
expects the science Inquisition oh I
love that yeah yeah from Monty Python
the science Inquisition well no the
Spanish right right yeah the science
Micah cook says I'm going from 25 an
hour to 14 an hour here in California
because I won't get the jab my kids will
have food that's only an excuse let's go
Brandon let's go Brandon yeah man
I'm never gonna eat out in a restaurant
in DC ever again we'll get used to it I
mean you'll get used to it we'll cook
we'll cook a lot more healthier well
instead of buying Choice we'll buy Prime
love to cook together that'll be fun
okay let's see enstein says in DC here
may have to get creative but compliance
isn't an option for me however the step
on snack crowd have here never shocks me
we finally got our no stop our step on
snack and find out shirts yeah they come
in aren't they top seller already right
they are their best selling shirt we've
ever had I love it so step on snack and
find out at the Tim cast store you can
pick it up yeah we've sold like
thousands of them it's crazy it's a good
shirt
um we got to get on our shirt game you
know I Luke does the like overtly
political shirts like he had one it was
fouchy as the emperor Emperor Force
lightning monkeys and dogs yeah I'm like
okay Luke's probably selling thousands
of these shirts because those are good
but we don't do that kind of shirt like
I don't do this show to make overt
political statements about that stuff
like step on snack and find out is a
meme it's like a silly combination of
memes and it doesn't it doesn't say
anything about Republicans Or democrats
or Fouch or anything like that the
gorilla thing I'm like I don't I don't
want to make overtly political
merchandise it can be like massively you
know just it should be fun cultural
stuff so that's what we're trying to
figure out we have I tested positive for
freedom and it's Luke riding an eagle
waving against in flag oh right where
Luke is Luke is to scale
on an eagle there's an eagle which is to
scale and then there's Luke he's right
on top of the eagle from Lord of the
Rings yes you know uh I challenged Luke
to a death match before the show and the
winner the winner was the only one who
arrived and Luke's not here he got
scared he did yeah he was like he was
like get out of here oh Jack's coming oh
no and then he was like uh my mom called
him my mommy called
there you go he's in the chat he was
posting stuff oh I bet he is he loves
those chats I've seen him stirring up s
in there all he's sitting next to me
stirring up s in the chats that guy Luke
Luke
you're not my father
all right let's see let's grab some
let's get some good conversation going
yeah are you trying to weed through the
super chats of all the uh well yeah a
lot of them are identical yeah yeah it's
like I can read one of them and like I
read one in the beginning but it's like
I can't just keep reading the same thing
over and over again yeah people are
obsessed about that man I don't get it
interesting
I honestly you know I I wonder about who
is we have substantially higher super
chats than we normally do so I don't
believe it's our normal audience got it
yeah you know because I think it's
people who are coming in here and just
just throwing money at Timmy hoping
hoping that you're going to embarrass me
in front of all these people that's an
interesting strategy yeah I like that I
can only I can only say this guys I'm
not on Elijah and Sydney's show I didn't
watch it we were doing this show when
that happened and
um and I'm and I don't wake up in the
morning I'm like I better go watch and
like figure out what this drama's all
about I'm like I wake up and I'm like
what did Joe Biden just say and like
what is Pelosi doing and what is Mitch
McConnell doing about it and what did he
just you know what's he what so I'm
spending my day like reading the news
and reading about what's going on and uh
I could not get in depth on this if I
wanted to it's just not my wheelhouse
well there's there's no depth to it
that's the thing it's nonsense so let's
read this we got William furry says
serious inquiry TP are you hiring I work
in medicine and feel so done with being
whipped around like a ragdoll with
mandates and exemptions uh we are hiring
and um the difficulty is you know we're
planting seeds of these new shows and
we're trying to grow them and they're
they're you know they're they're but
baby birds we are unable to kick out of
the nest they can't fly on their own so
the core Tim cast show is like
subsidizing the growth of these new
shows so we can hire but it's like
everything we hire outside of this show
is a loss and that's what we've been
doing so it's like we're taking the risk
to try and do more stuff we have the
book Tales from the inverted world at
invertedworldbook.com it's a bestseller
now which is amazing amazing
congratulations you're a publisher now
that's right
um and that's good but as much as the
external stuff we've started has made
money it's not covering its own costs
right so in order for us to keep hiring
those have to grow to a certain point
and it's not easy and it's very
difficult look I put out the call all
the time for conservative donors to fund
media projects that don't have immediate
returns right away and Tim I'm very
proud of you for taking this route and
investing in things that don't have
returns right away in order to move the
needle so kudos to you my friends I'm
really look so the first Tales from the
inverted world book we have it's like
General stories you know uh the next
book The Ghost of the Civil War I can't
say too much because it would ruin some
of the book
but Shane Went Down to Georgia and he
started investigating lost Confederate
gold and it got dangerous
it got like legit dangerous I don't want
to spoil too much but someone died
on the crew so no no no no like your
insurance must be through the roof one
of one of the one of the let me just say
this one of the sources in the process
in the investigation oh my God died and
threats were made and so I'm like this
is gonna be crazy dude that's awesome do
you have a hot mic where the guy
confesses to a murderer in the last
episode because that was sick dude
yeah what was the documentary about that
guy who's a real estate developer rich
guy who went around killing a couple of
people and they did this whole this was
a whole HBO documentary and in the last
where they uh Durst maybe now I can't
remember where they they interviewed him
and they were like did you murder these
girls no did you murdered them no did
you murdered them no and in the final
scene of the documentary he's he's got a
mic on during the interview he gets up
he's like let me go to the bathroom he
goes into the bathroom and he doesn't
realize that the mic is on and he's like
I killed those ladies but they're never
gonna find out just keep lying just keep
lying or whatever just keep lying just
keep lying and he walks out and they're
all like yo your mic was on and he
confessed at the end and it was all
legit it was it was amazing on HBO okay
we don't got anything like to catch a
ketchup killer or catch a murderer or
something I can't I can't remember what
was it called yeah man that was awesome
um but so if you would like to get a job
um jobs at timcast.com I'll I'll write
your name down we'll keep a lookout
I am writing your name down what is the
name William fur oh I got it and um yeah
man we're we're gonna we're gonna we'll
we'll go through it you know we look
through jobs periodically we try to
figure out what makes sense and what we
can do for people we have 31 employees
oh
that's right 31 because we are like my
attitude is yo we gotta start planting
trees yep we gotta plant trees now
definitely and then hopefully in 10
years we got big trees with beautiful
shade and you know we'll have like a
banana tree and we'll have actually they
don't grow trees if they go on bushes or
something yeah oh my boy Matt just
texted he said it was the Robert Durst
documentary your boy Matt we got you
Robert Robert Durst
MK 90 says I'm officially getting
separated from the Marine Corps with an
with an other than honorable discharge
for refusal of vaccine open criticism of
the government and memes the core and
people who support this government have
lost their honor
that's that's it's busted man
feel for those people making those tough
choices ma'am
all right
let's see heck that was me
and you know what ultimate the
resolution was is I informed my children
I gave them all the information I could
possibly give them and I was like look
it's up to you JC says Tim do you agree
that this started with accepting the
mask requirements if so do you regret
not opposing that earlier well it
started before the mass requirements it
started with two weeks to slow the
spread I don't regret
um uh Mass requirements within reason
it's it's more so it's not so much like
are you for against masks well let me
start from the beginning I agreed with
two weeks to slow the spread why made
sense we want to slow the curve down we
want to make sure that the infection
spreads we don't overload our ICU beds
because then tons of people will die
because we can't treat them and I said
okay make sense that was a mistake
that was a mistake I agree with it back
then now I would say in hindsight I
realized the exploitation it then moves
on to mass requirements
within reason absolutely I think they're
bad but I will say my point is this
ultimately to uh put on a mask to walk
in somewhere for a few minutes and walk
out wasn't that big of a deal to undergo
an irreversible and permanent medical
procedure is an absolute deal breaker
there are certain things where we say
like okay sure fine whatever it's like
I'll put the mask on I'll take it off
it'll be five minutes I will tell you
this now I will not go to any business
that mandates a mask I don't do it so
out here in West Virginia uh just yet
just last week or whatever I was with
Allison we went to a cafe and then a big
huge thing on the door saying please
wear a mask and I said Starbucks over
there doesn't require mess so instead of
going to the small business that needed
our money very very much
um I went to the big corporate store
because the big corporate store was like
do your thing we don't care and so there
it is
um if I have a choice it will not be to
to to comply with any of this stuff so
we went to Micro Center had to wear a
mask well that that was tough I needed
to get a GPU we needed to get equipment
for the studio to expand and so I'm like
look put it on a mask for 20 minutes to
walk in and walk out it's not the end of
the world if I did if I had a choice I
wouldn't do it but I need to buy this
thing right now so I will I don't like
that at all
give me a choice I'll say no I went to
the mall to buy my wife to be the one
very gift I wanted to get her and I had
got to the gate of the door and they
were like put a mask on and I was like
sorry and I just walked away I just
can't do it anymore well not anymore I
have walked out of a hundred stores that
have asked me to put on a mask I just
will not do it I will not give them my
money I will not go to the stores I will
not comply I've left it up to my kids to
make their own decisions because you
know what they're teenagers they can
make their own decisions but for me I am
able to be comfortable and resist and I
will if you get the 30 70 what'd you get
we got yeah we got the latest if I went
to a store at Micro Center and they were
like vaccine only I'd be like all right
walk away yeah if YouTube emailed me and
said we now require everyone to have
proof of vaccination YouTube creators I
feel like later that's the end yeah baby
it's I mean I'm just reeling from this
notion I've just learned the news today
that DC has a vax mandate now I'm
literally never going to be able to go
to any of my favorite restaurants in DC
any I can't go to any single bars or
restaurants in the city that I have
lived in for 30 years that's a thing yep
that's a thing no museums no concerts no
movies no gyms no yoga no nothing you
can't even go to a hotel
right
that's a that's a lot to process
actually I gotta deal with that in
Chicago it's gonna be funny we'll see
what happens I have a feeling No One's
Gonna enforce it at least where we're
going all right this is a good one Eric
a says Tim I appreciate all the work you
do in regards to the news but your takes
on entertainment suck more than a
struggling actress yeah
that was a sick burn you got me
um but the reality is it um
my takes on entertainment are as
pleasurable as a struggling actress
[Laughter]
all right let's put it that way
memes memes memes skimming skimming
skimming well but I always do this this
is normal yeah
and we'll we'll read a couple more here
Dan scope says I'm 31 and the captain in
the military 12 years of my life
committed to service and soon I'll be
starting over from scratch and refusing
to follow a lawful order any advice for
starting over great show
oh man one foot in front of the other
yeah one foot in front of the other and
never stop the Journey of a Thousand
Miles begins with a single step
it's got to figure it out man
look I want to address one more thing
from the from the article and the stuff
that's coming up in the chats
people are saying that I use this word
little girls and they're trying to make
it out like I'm some sort of you know
come on guys little girls is about BDSM
daddy little girl let's just put that
out there I'm older she's younger people
come to me it's a kink thing daddy
little girl get over it guys I'm sorry
that I had sex y'all get a life dude
jeez
whatever man next uh I'm Gonna Keep uh
I said this a couple weeks ago I would
forgive Jesse smallett if you apologized
yeah I would uh I forgive Joyce out if
you apologized I'm not I'm not I don't
know anything I'm not here to to play
with uh you know stupid drama issues
yeah I want to talk about uh important
issues and expanding and growing and you
know whatever all right Alan Alin Jin
says so as a billionaire Tim you would
just be paying Michael malice to be
Michael malice just on a bigger scale oh
yeah yes we would man I would I would be
like Michael what's your budget
requirement do everything it'd be
amazing
um but it's more than just money though
I will admit Michael needs to be a press
secretary for you know in a presidential
campaign he needs there's there's
positions you can get to without you
know with money without money so
but yeah definitely I just be like
here's a million dollars Michael like
please continue to be yourself and just
do more of this I'd actually be like do
you know anyone else we could hire to be
on Twitter doing the same thing and it
would be like Tim Poole runs this
propaganda farm with all these people on
Twitter what do they do they post weird
trolling posts I can't I don't know make
people look dumb I guess
Michael's the guy that I would like to
make contact with I haven't been able to
to get in touch with him he's
interesting oh yeah he's out in Austin
yeah
all right let's read a couple more let's
read a couple more
wow we're getting just so many super
chats
just rack it up buy me some more top
shelf Japanese booze with this man would
you Eggman says so if people disagree or
point something out that you don't like
surely they can't be your usual audience
come on man no I didn't say that what
I'm saying that if
so if we if we have thousands of dollars
in super chats that we don't normally
get that means there's more people here
giving us super chats than they normally
do that's what I'm saying yeah and uh
people who are observing who are friends
of mine or whatever they're texting me
about the chat so like it seems like a
different crew in there although I gotta
say ordinarily the chats are pretty
vicious anyways there's pretty there's
like bots in there there's people being
mean in there it's an interesting place
for people to get their sort of jollies
I think it's funny that you know I know
was it like November 7th I said Joe
Biden won the election and all the Trump
people were like Tim Poole is a loser
Right and started yelling at me and I'm
like well I guess whatever like I don't
know people think that I'm gonna change
my opinions because they're young men
yelling at me and chat and then people
are saying like I'm unsubscribing or
whatever and I'm like I guess yo if you
don't like me like I'm sorry you don't
like me you're not you're allowed not to
and you're free to watch the data
doesn't bear that out though does it
well no look I'll say this right now if
there's a bunch of people who are
watching big fans to the show and
they're mad at me over my stance on this
then with respect I genuinely mean this
I'm sorry I let you down and if you
don't want to watch show anymore then
you know that's the choice you've made I
can only be me and I will only ever be
me so if you don't like it then maybe
there's nothing more I can do maybe
maybe I'm not the guy for you I don't
know uh we're gonna keep doing these
shows there you go Tim all right let's
uh we'll read a couple more here let's
see bazinski says when are you creating
Tim coin and nfts workout nfts we're
working on all the art the porches we
have of creating just like a digital
version of the art you know we we had
like some funny ideas and there were
like Trading Card versions and I was
like no no no
I don't want to sell likeness on a
trading card we just have portraits of
people they signed and we want to post
the pictures of them and then give
people their like you know nft version
of it the digital version of the
physical version
all right
let's see let's get uh we'll get a Super
Chat down here the scroll time in
between chats is longer than usual today
it's not longer than usual there's no
Luke and Ian to keep talking while I'm
scrolling oh that's true there you go I
I killed Luke before the show true he
did it was Bloody there is only one and
it is I Tyler Miel says would love to
come ride your skatepark with you from
MD love the show Tim
um we're thinking about doing an open
skate night the problem is liability
like we weren't able to get people here
so we need to get the new space if I
tried to ollie I would break my ankle
immediately
all right let's see there was one yeah
we break my ankle on the skateboard
ing okay let's see
um
there was one I was looking for kind of
disappeared after I must have someone
must have removed it no okay okay here
it is
so Dima cold
coldis says did you jack make amends to
Sydney honestly all I care about 100 uh
I made amends to her within a handful of
hours uh privately she responded she
accepted my apology she offered her own
apology she in no way uh intended to put
me in a bad spot and she acknowledged
that she didn't pick up on the signals
and the direct requests that I was
making of her to not talk about that
subject she apologized to me I apologize
to her we made up Elijah and I went out
that night we made up uh you know we
apologized we made up everything is all
good with me Sydney and Elijah and we've
been dming about this being like why are
people still talking about this why
doesn't everybody just let it go yo me
and Sydney are cool everybody else
should be cool the reason I want to read
that last one just in case anybody who
joined in and didn't know that you like
they may have seen drama or whatever and
didn't know that you you guys had like
you had apologized and everything yeah
and I did publicly on my Twitter also I
just want to say this
if you guys want to win a culture War
you have to forgive people
if you want to lose a culture War you
can be like the cancel culture leftists
and engage in a circular firing squad
but that's why you know when when when
Joey salads first like tweeted at me and
I snapped at him I was like that's a big
mistake that's a big big mistake you
know Joey's Joey's got his platform he's
an influent influential guy I should
hear what he has to say I should talk to
him about it if he's genuinely saying
he's sorry then I should I should
absolutely you know like work with him
on this because we want people to to be
on the right side of freedom and liberty
and then people are like yeah but he's
only apologizing because his career will
end if he doesn't and I'm like well okay
then if we can make him be a better
person because he's got a fear behind it
I'm like at the very least he'll be
doing good that's what I just say man
anybody who apologizes I'm willing to
give forgiveness within certain to a
certain extent with that being said
smash that like button if you like the
show and if you don't feel free to not
like smash the like button or whatever
but also go to timcast.com become a
member it's a it's a very Merry
Christmas it's a very Merry Christmas to
all all of you we have two trees here at
the timcast HQ because we celebrate
double Christmas and um presents under
the tree it's better than one two two
yes and uh for for everybody who
celebrates other holidays you know uh
much respect to your holidays as well
happy holidays Happy Hanukkah you know
and whatever what um I'm not familiar
with many of the other holidays
otherwise I would say that but uh we
here at CPS compound we're very into
Christmas it's just always been our you
know I grew up with Christmas it's my
thing you guys if you don't do Christmas
much respect do your thing we'll do our
Christmas have a good time and we're
gonna go off to the city and enjoy
ourselves so thanks for hanging out with
us thanks for everything thanks for
smashing the like button thanks for
subscribing thanks for making this year
absolutely amazing the New Year's New
Year's is going to be a whole lot of fun
we're not going to be working on New
Year's Eve it's a Friday and nobody
wants to come so there's nothing I can
do about it I was like we're gonna get
on New Year's and everyone's like we're
not going we're gonna be partying and
I'm lying all right so that's what's
happening but uh I really appreciate it
thank you so much everybody for for
sticking with us for the year and
watching next year is going to get
absolutely crazy with uh with the
midterm elections so
yeah you can follow the show at
timcastiro basically everywhere else you
can subscribe to this channel you can
follow me at timcast on Instagram or
Twitter or whatever if you want I just
troll on Twitter it's just ridiculous
nonsense Jack you wanna you wanna shout
anything out yeah man uh thanks to
everybody for listening and tuning in uh
Jack bro oh sorry Jack Murphy live on
Twitter Jack Murphy live on YouTube
great podcast very in-depth Evergreen
issues philosophy politics culture Etc
jacked brunch
227 Washington D.C Tim oh I don't know
oh no no no no no well look oh that's
true we'll call it the Washington DC
metropolitan area we will find a the
closest jurisdiction uh it may end up
being here but 227 jacked brunch j c k e
d brunch.com Tim will be there Lydia
will be there Ian will be there Luke is
dead so he won't be there oh I got a
place what's up I got a place in mind
all right we'll talk about it yeah we'll
talk about the show there's going to be
well over 100 people there it's going to
be awesome
it's on a Sunday on a Sunday it's a
Sunday brunch bro I got a place yeah we
gotta call him now though all right
let's do it all right after the show
after the show don't announce it I won't
I won't people will cancel us
and I am also here thank you for joining
Jack thank you Liz thanks for having me
yeah I'm
excited for Christmas as well I feel
like
my life I'm very optimistic for the
future excited about the new year you
guys might follow me on Twitter at Sarah
patchlitz excellent all right everybody
have an excellent Christmas have a happy
holiday and we will see you all next
Monday when we are back thanks for
hanging out bye guys thanks